Five for
Abby Martin,
Ladies and gentlemen,
how are you?
Great.
How are you today to be here?
Shit's going down.
Exactly.
It's a crazy day for bill cosby.
Woopsies Hey,
I'm,
I'm reeling in that news man.
Yeah,
I was,
I was wondering what was gonna happen
because the first one was a mistrial was
that would happen.
Yeah,
but what,
so what's the difference between this
one?
Is this a civil suit or is this,
I think these are these fines.
Civil.
This was a,
the retrial,
so he got convicted of charges,
felony,
sexual assault,
three different counts.
Each one carries,
I think at least 10 years.
He could go to jail for 30 years,
which is death for him.
I mean,
he's,
he's already blind.
Yeah,
he's very,
yeah,
he's uh,
he could barely see.
Right.
Good.
I'm so happy that he's getting charged
at the end of his life.
That's amazing.
He's a creepy dude.
He liked to have sex with lifeless dead
bodies.
Yeah.
We were trying to,
I mean,
purely speculation,
right?
Like what would cause someone to want to
do that?
Like what,
but I,
I have this theory,
I think a lot of people did that shit in
the 60s I think in the 60s it was a
normal thing to drug people and I think
they,
you know,
remember the terms.
Have you ever,
you've heard it slipping someone a
mickey?
They,
I think they used to do that all the
time back then and they didn't think
anything of it.
You know,
if he's disgusting,
people are fucking cross.
If you just go back a couple of hundred
years,
like I'm watching the show vikings,
it's great show by the way.
I don't know if you ever wash it out,
but uh,
you know,
they were obviously fucking crazy
people.
They did wild shit.
But it was common.
I mean this was how people live.
They would storm into villages and kill
everybody.
This was normal shit just a thousand
years ago or so.
And I think if you go back just a
hundred years,
the way people treated each other was
horrific.
If you go back 50 years ago,
that's bill cosby's era.
I mean,
I really think that people back then
were different.
They didn't have the Internet,
they didn't,
they didn't understand how other people
were viewing their activity.
They thought they could hide this
activity.
And I think there was a group of people
specifically,
you know,
partiers that would drug people and I
think it was a normal thing.
I think there's probably a lot of people
out there that are here in this bill
cosby thing and they're thinking about
all the times that they did it.
That is horrifying.
It's fucking scary.
Especially when you catch yourself in it
being this like responsible,
like I'm in a lecture.
All the black people pull up your pants.
Yeah,
be good.
I remember one time Wanda Sykes
interviewed him at something and he was
a chastising her on the way she was
talking English and he was wearing
sunglasses inside and he's like,
sorry,
I'm just recovering off the raping that
I just said.
I can't see people.
You can't look you in the eyes and I'll
raped out.
Oh my God,
I'm so happy to hear this.
And did you see Weinstein chased out of
that bar like in Florida or whatever?
Some guy comes up and like slap,
oh,
slapped him in the face.
Hopefully that happens to him all over
the
world.
I think that he's a disgusting pig who
should be chased out of every public
forum.
I was just a lot of those out there.
There's a lot,
a lot of creepy humans in this world.
You know,
I just,
I think we're in this unprecedented time
of understanding in terms of like the
consequences of your behavior,
what you can and can't do now,
and then the fact that people will just,
if you're doing something horrific to
people,
other people are now going to know.
Whereas you know,
like again,
50 years ago nobody fucking knew
anything.
Like,
think about JFK,
right?
Think about all the shit that's going on
with trump and trump just kind of this,
it's like water off a duck's back with
trump for whatever reason.
So he's got some strange ability to just
like fake nose.
That's his brand.
His brand is being a misogynist piece.
Yeah,
it's spelled lightheart.
Well,
it's also,
he does,
he's,
he just says it's lies and he just keeps
going and everybody knows it's not a lie
and be like,
what are you going to do it while he's
not freaking out,
he's acting like businesses usual and
somehow or another that's okay.
Like it's,
but if you go back to like what JFK was
up to,
like JFK was a fucking freak and
everybody knows it.
It's like,
Yep.
Comic.
But he was a freak in the area,
in the era where the press knew
everything that was going on and
everybody like kind of kept her mouth
shut.
And everybody,
there was like an unspoken agreement
that they wouldn't report on affairs and
all the other stuff.
And it's just,
it's fascinating to see our culture
change wildly over a short period of
time.
Yeah.
The tabloid journalism has taken
completely over.
I mean,
it's true.
It's good,
but um,
to see what these people are really
doing.
But yeah,
you're totally right.
JFK was a complete womanizer and it's
like lauded as this hero still,
I think everybody was back then.
I think that's what they did.
That's why they want it to be present in
the first place so they can just fuck
everything that moves.
I'll try to save the free world where
it's fucking weird.
You know?
W W we're in a strange time.
I think historians in the future,
when they go back to the period where
the Internet was created essentially was
like 94 when it became mainstream.
I think they're going to look at this
time between 94 and 2018 is
unprecedented explosion of change.
Trump is nuts.
I don't understand why,
you know,
the stormy Daniels thing I feel like
could be,
isn't doing,
I don't think anything is going to come
out of the Russia stuff.
I think that if anything,
it's going to come out of the Michael
Cohen.
Yeah.
Okay.
But Hen pardoning Libya is basically him
sending a message saying,
don't worry man,
I got your back.
I'm in a part in you.
If you go to jail to come.
And I think cause I mean,
why the hell?
Why else?
Why else would you just pardon Dick
Cheney's former man.
Oh yeah,
scooter libby.
I don't understand that.
It was just him basically just being
like,
don't worry bro.
Got Your back.
I'll get you out of prison if Bush,
pardon that guy.
Right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's insane.
The trump stuff's nuts.
The stormy Daniels thing is ridiculous.
Did you see that interview with Anderson
Cooper?
No,
I didn't watch that.
And that's,
I mean,
it just,
the craziest part about it is not the
fact that
he had sex with a porn star and that she
was trying to do a transactional thing
to get on the apprentice.
It's that he's sent someone a threatened
her and her child after that.
He's fucking nuts.
Yeah.
I think,
does he capable of,
you know,
I think that's standard operational
procedure for lot of people.
He's a man.
He's a mafia acting dude.
Well that wasn't that what,
who,
who was saying that about,
oh,
call me.
Call me was saying that it was
essentially you're reminded him of when
he was prosecuting the mob that they
have this sort of,
you know,
same kind of attitude.
This us versus them keep everything
together.
Loyalty is everything.
Totally.
Um,
by the way,
great job at stand up.
I've been going to a bunch of standup
shows.
Everyone just talks about jerking off to
pixelated porn in the 80s and their
dicks.
And I mean you,
you,
you're set was awesome and I really
encourage everyone to check it out.
It's just,
it was amazing.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it was really fucking on a Netflix
special last weekend.
How was,
it was great.
I'm very excited.
Very happy.
What is it called?
I haven't decided yet.
The tour I was calling strange times.
Cause you know,
obviously we're in strange times.
I might just keep that.
I don't know.
I made my change the name.
I'd have a really,
haven't decided.
I was impressed.
There's a lot of really good jokes about
trump,
which is you would think would be easy.
But I guess for Comedians it's probably
not easy because it's so satirical that
we're living in.
Well yeah,
the problem is reality is already a
joke.
It's like,
so it's so crazy that you have to have,
you have to figure out what is your
unique perspective,
you know,
if you have one,
I just think we're very childlike in
what we do with an,
you know,
how we treat our leaders and how we
choose our leaders.
And I'm really fascinated by the cult of
personality that goes behind really any
big time leader,
whether it's trump or Obama,
there's people that think that person
can do no wrong.
I was very fascinated by that.
With Hillary.
There was a giant group of people that
refuse to look at any of the things that
Hillary was doing that were wrong.
Any of the things like the Clinton
Foundation or those speeches that she
was giving to these bankers where she
wouldn't release the transcripts or the
lies that she would talk about.
The difference between Colome's version
of what the FBI had found her to have
done wrong versus her version of it.
And there's a video where you see the
two of them back to back and she's a
deceptive person.
She's clearly a liar.
She's not,
she's not a good person.
She's not like this shining example of
what we would like our leader to be.
We'd like our lead like love or hate or
Obama.
What that guy was.
To me it was like a statesman.
Like he's so the way he would
communicate with so calm and smooth and
he was,
you know,
if he,
even if he didn't like his policy,
you got to admit the guy was incredibly
articulate,
beautifully literate,
like the way he would speak and
communicate.
He was well read like he to me
represented what I would like the
version of the person who's running the
big thing to be.
And I think that's the whole crux of,
of people who have brainwashed
themselves into thinking there's some
sort of like deep state apparatus that's
outing trump.
I think that their real problem,
look,
the deep state is the military
industrial complex.
They're winning at the end of the day,
no matter what defense contractors,
stocks are skyrocketing,
trump is basically the de facto arms
salesmen and chief on the phone at the
Japanese prime minister being like hog
these killer drones bro.
Like we got to sell these surveillance
drones.
That's who's going to win.
At the end of the day,
the neo liberal establishment is who
hates him because he removes the mask of
empire,
right?
That's what he does.
He removes the mask.
He's making it less palatable to sell
imperialism around the world,
and I think that's,
that's the crux of why you see a kind of
these think tankers and the liberals on
on TV,
and we can get into this later,
but there's a whole misnomer going on
about the left and a miss
characterization about the left.
The left has no fucking power in this
country.
The left has no voice in terms of news
coverage.
So all these people,
she has not left.
She has a new liberal corporate shill.
You,
you say that and so does Jimmy Dore.
Jimmy Dore says the same thing.
Yeah.
He just thinks that she does not
represent
the left,
not at all.
And there's a myth of,
of the fact that the media is liberal in
general.
I think that,
you know,
tv,
culture aside,
news is not,
there is no liberal media.
Media is owned by multinational
corporations,
with conservative business owners that
have interlocking boards of director.
It's at defense contractors,
Monsanto,
et Cetera.
Those people are fucking liberal.
They're not left.
They pushed down their policies.
It doesn't matter if you're a Maoist
working at Washington Times,
you're not gonna be able to put out that
contradictory narrative that your
shareholders are pushing.
Um,
it's,
it's really unfortunate that the left
has been basically,
I don't know,
I mean they've just demonize the entire
left where now you have the NRA
fomenting civil war against the fucking
left.
Trump and all of his followers are just
like the left is what's really wrong
with this country where there's no
power.
We don't have any power.
You have given me like I have more of a
platform than probably any other leftist
because you have given me a platform on
the show.
When have you ever heard my views?
Like on TV ever?
You know what I mean?
Well,
when you were on tv,
I heard them,
which is why we go to archie.
It's nuts.
Yeah.
But that's a weird thing to write
because people think of Russia.
Russia is the great enemy and you were
on Russia today.
That'd be Martins.
She's a tool of the Russians,
the Russians,
the Russians.
The Russians were nothing forever like
the Russians,
like we got through the Cold War,
like all the Russians are friends now
who,
because when I was in high school we
were always worried we're going to get
bombed by the Russians.
That shit went over.
Why does it feel to just have that back?
It feels weird.
I don't believe it.
I don't believe we're going to get
bombed by the Russians.
I don't think we're going to bomb them.
I don't think they're going to bomb us.
And I think as cliche as it sounds,
mutually assured is probably a really
good incentive to not launch missiles
into the air.
I think that's still real.
What do you think about the serious
stuff?
Scares the shit out of me.
Everything.
Anything to do with Isis,
anything to do with like ideological
warfare.
All that stuff scares the shit out of
me.
You know,
when you,
when you see what people are capable of
doing,
if they really believe in their cause
and they really believe God's on their
side,
they really believe.
And also if you really believe you've
been fucked over by the Great Satan,
all that stuff scares the shit out of me
because most people were blissfully
unaware of what the United States and
you know,
what the commander in chief or whoever
the fuck is pulling the strings is doing
overseas and what the repercussions of
those actions is going to be.
Okay.
Yeah.
That,
that the guy who I think,
I don't know when the Quebec Mosque
mosque shooting was,
but his basically his justification was,
you know,
Islamic terrorism won.
It made me do this.
So if that's the case,
what are all the people that we kill
with drones?
And we just killed the bride at a
fucking wedding party in Yemen.
So another one of those,
yes.
Bomb wedding part at least eight.
I think that's our thing.
Yeah.
And it's deliberate because we're
supplying intelligence and weapons to
Saudi Arabia.
It's not just,
you know,
we supply them weapons and turned a
blind eye.
We are supplying military intelligence
and targets for them to bomb and we're
actively helping them do that.
So yeah,
they just bombed another wedding party
on top of the funerals,
but all schools.
But why are they,
why wedding parties is,
was there someone in the wedding party
they were trying to get,
or was it a mistake?
I don't even know what the official line
is,
but how many wedding parties can you
bomb before we draw our red line?
I mean,
it's just disgusting.
And they killed the bride.
They killed the fucking,
so what are all these people who grow
up?
This was supposed to be the happiest day
of their lives and now you know,
are they gonna grow up wanting to,
to kill Americans?
I mean,
blaming the marriage.
Yeah.
If you were conspiracy theorists,
that's what you'd say.
You would say the reason why they're
doing this is that the United States
wants an endless war.
The best way to insure it and this war
is to occasionally blow up some people
that really have no dog in the fight.
And you create a bunch of radicals.
You create people that are hell bent on
revenge because that,
that's the real hardcore conspiracy
theory,
the Alex Jones take on it.
I think that,
uh,
a good way to look at the world as,
you know,
there's the colonizers and colonize the,
the,
the states that are basically remaining
that we know that the establishment or
the empire wants to take down.
And Iran,
Syria,
Venezuela,
North Korea,
right?
What,
what do they all have in common?
They're all,
uh,
independent of our economic a Gemini.
And so we use our economic and military
might to commit violence around the
world,
to subject these countries to bend to
our will economically.
And it's really obvious and
unfortunately people just continue to
buy into this humanitarian bullshit
propaganda no matter who's in office.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter who's in office.
If you look at like the actions that the
Obama administration took versus the
action the Bush administration took
their super similar.
Yeah.
And this whole deep state thing.
I mean,
look,
as junior I the deep state,
the deep state I think is
the military industrial complex.
It's the machine that churns on no
matter who is the commander in chief,
it doesn't matter.
Right?
They're not trying to get rid of trump.
Absolutely not.
They love him,
dude.
Right?
They love this.
So look,
trump has a lot of enemies because he's
a scorched earth.
Like he pissed a lot of people off.
So of course you have tons of people who
hate him.
It appears that the media is uniformly
against him,
but I think it's because God can we pull
up that Kanye club look okay,
Kanye on and look up Vic Berger,
Kanye on Ellen.
This Shit Burger on twitter.
Twitter's an animal.
Did He,
have you seen the ellen one where Kanye,
isn't it?
Oh Man.
Recent.
No,
it's just amazing.
Just something he put together.
Yeah.
Wow.
Hold on a second.
Wait,
look at Ellen.
Just look at his face.
When was this from?
No,
maybe
we're looking at Kanye can want more
children.
Make crazy faces now he gets really good
one more.
This camp where he is in the bed.
Yeah.
That a context.
The real question.
That way it gets really good though.
Okay.
I'm with you.
What does he say?
Oh yeah.
He's in the building.
Oh,
read this part.
What's dead?
Picasso.
Steve jobs is dead.
What?
Disney is dead.
I'm dead.
What?
Look at that one.
It Ain't no joke is rock cam said.
Did you see that?
He wrote that he was going to be the
next president died from TMZ.
They called them erratic.
He's like,
please don't call me erratic.
You're speaking to your next president.
Oh my God.
Did you see Kim say like,
look,
you guys,
Connie was just living in the future in
a couple of years.
Um,
someone else is going to say what he
does and you're going to praise him.
Oh,
it's like,
really?
Yeah.
She's just trying to keep him home.
Just like she's got to say whatever she
can keep it from vanishing.
So bizarre though,
right?
Yeah.
I wish I knew what was really going on.
Like Jamie thinks it's a big part of it,
a big publicity stunt because he's got
an album coming out.
Look at them,
look at them nodding a million percent.
Miller's a huge tracking number.
All you have to do is be,
you know,
a token person and like the joy villa
woman who was like,
all right,
I'm going to wear a trump dress to the
grammys and then I'm going to just
gonna,
you know,
sell tons of records because there is a
huge vacuum to be filled of trump
supporters
who are looking for people like this.
There's definitely that.
It's fascinating to me.
It's really interesting because he's
changed the wha what's possible.
And this is one thing that trump has
absolutely done.
Like when he won,
like Nag changes who can be president,
it really does because it's now like,
okay,
we know that the,
I mean we've,
we've already decided we're willing to
elect someone that we know really
probably shouldn't be doing it.
So now what?
Like we're just electing a famous
person.
So what's,
who is that?
Well,
what about Oprah?
Yeah.
It's like,
no.
Well,
how about fucking NBC tweeted,
you know,
our president,
oh,
like a speech by our president gives a
good fucking speech and then we should
vote them into office.
Who the fuck is in control of the NBC
twitter page?
They wrote something about a speech from
our all cabs president.
Like what?
Wait a minute.
I thought the rock was going to run for
a while.
And then I was like,
yeah,
well,
and then I saw that he had had big
dinner with the Saudi king and he was
like,
Oh man,
like next time I'm bringing the Tequila
to your house.
And everyone was like,
Saudi Arabia is a dry country dude.
Like,
and he was like,
Oh shit.
And then he deleted the tweet.
It's like,
obviously you just drank a giant bottle
of Tequila with the king and the king's
not Saudi Arabia.
Yeah.
Oh.
And,
and um,
who else was there?
Oh,
Morgan Freeman.
The Voice of God and Hillary Clinton's
soul was,
was with the Rock and the king of Saudi
Arabia.
Somehow this is cool,
you know,
but,
but Sharla sod is a monster,
yet the king of Saudi Arabia is a cool
dude who we should have dinner with.
That makes sense.
Is this the young king that's trying to
like,
yeah.
What is his deal?
He's like,
he locked up all those people for who
the hell knows?
Probably to consolidate power.
I mean that was the line that came out
was like,
oh,
he's,
you know,
he's revolutionary.
He's reformist.
But I mean,
I think that it was just to consolidate
power is a power grab and goes,
hey,
come on as a Saudi Arabia,
listen to it can even drive there now.
So why don't you relax?
They can write but not at night or
something like that.
Hey.
Right.
They still have to have their mail and
guardian escort them around.
So Dude,
last time we were on,
wow.
Crazy,
crazy stuff happened after that.
Right.
New jobs,
gigantic pile of email,
thankfully to the wrong email address.
But I still was aware of them,
uh,
have a bunch of people and it was a,
it was like a,
a form letter.
Um,
talking about how you're a liar and
you're anti Israel and none of this
stuff is happening between Israel and
the,
I just,
yeah,
it was,
it got weird.
It got weird.
It was like a hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of emails
and that's,
and that's a campaign that's a campaign
with large amount of money behind it
because the Israeli lobby likes to come
down very hard on people who speak out
against the crimes of Israel.
As you see,
this is a third rail issue.
No one talks about it even though it's
so fucking obvious.
I mean,
we heard the mantra,
Putin kills journalists all the time.
Well,
Israeli of forces are sniping
journalists and children on camera and
yet the world turns a blind eye.
Well,
someone got killed just a few days ago.
A journalist just died yesterday.
He was shot in the abdomen.
Yeah,
they're all Palestinian.
There's been no Israeli casualties,
wounded or otherwise.
But yes,
stand with us is a,
is directly funded by the Israeli
government.
It's part of their giant Hasbro
operation.
And that's,
they made a video.
They were promoting a video,
kind of trying to debunk what I said on
here.
Look,
you can look at the empire files and see
all of the documentation of what I said.
That's your style.
That's all my stuff.
Yeah,
the empire files on the empire files.tv
and it's a youtube channel that you can
subscribe to too.
But I mean it's just very easy,
easily verifiable facts like that
Israeli military law governs the West
Bank.
This is verifiable in five seconds on
Amnesty International.
So it was just very desperate measures
to try to obfuscate what I was saying.
And this is really all they have left
because the tide is turning man.
I mean,
look,
Natalie Portman just signed on to
boycott this conference in Israel and
they are running scared.
I mean,
they're trying to revoke her citizenship
because she's basically participating in
bds.
Um,
because she said recent events have made
her greatly disturbed as it should
disturb everyone.
The fact that there's this ongoing
massacre.
And if I could just explain to people
what's going on really quickly,
it is horrifying you guys.
I mean,
there's a thing called the great march
of return,
and it's been completely nonviolent on
the side of Palestinians.
It's in Gaza,
which is the open air prison where about
2 million people are housed in cage like
animals,
and they're not allowed to leave.
I can't think of any other place in the
world that refugees actually can't leave
otherwise there'll be shot.
So there's like Israeli guard posts
surrounding this place that count their
calories.
They,
they don't let them have concrete
anything that can be construed as a
weapon,
et cetera.
So anyway,
they,
they're protesting this,
right because they have no dignity,
no humanity,
no agency to live their lives.
And so they're protesting nonviolently.
They're going up to the,
to the fence and you know,
thousands and thousands of them and 40
people have just been executed.
There's Israeli soldiers sitting up
perched on a hilltop with sniper scopes.
This isn't just random gunfire that
people are being hit with.
They are deliberately attacking every
single person with head shots,
with genitalia shots.
It's sick and press.
There's people marked press.
I mean,
that's an egregious war crime.
Yeah.
You have Nikki Haley,
uh,
vetoing every single UN resolution or
investigation into Israel.
I can't imagine another country.
So I think that you look,
Israel can only survive with us
sponsorship and we love to have that
beach head in the Middle East.
We love to have that military garrison
because we use Israel.
Like what happened in Syria,
we used as real to bomb Syria first to
test the waters.
We use Israeli forces to execute nuclear
scientists in Iran.
We use the massage to do all kinds of
stuff so that we love to have that kind
of,
you know,
military,
post outpost in the Middle East that we
can use to try to intimidate all those
postcolonial states that are independent
or we want to overthrow.
So I think that's why,
you know,
a lot of people say,
oh,
the lobby controls us and I think that
that's wrong.
Um,
I think that there's a lot of lobbies
that have influenced,
but I think it's,
it's more strategic than that.
I really do.
And so
for the Palestinians,
the Palestinians that are trapped in
Gaza and if they leave,
there's no other way to go other than
through Israel.
Yeah.
Well they,
yes.
And a lot of people are like,
oh,
well what about Egypt and Jordan?
They can,
they can try to go out that way.
No,
I mean basically they're all in cahoots
with the Netanyahu is administration and
they're all basically client states of
the u s so no,
they can't leave.
And Israel controls their water,
the passageways,
everything that they don't let them
leave.
Like a lot of these people who have been
shot with sniper rifles can't even get
treatment because they're denied
treatment.
So there's so many amputations that are
totally unnecessary.
So now that you have like thousands of
people who are just amputated,
5,000 people have been shot with live
ammunition and you've been there.
And how much time did you spend when you
were there?
So I was in the West Bank for a month
and they let you go back and forth from
Gaza to know.
Unfortunately I was banned from Gaza
because I was told I was a propagandist.
And I was not a real journalist and I
was told I was an Iranian agent,
which was confusing because I thought it
was a Russian agent who was the press
minister of Israel who,
yeah.
Yeah.
So I think they thought it was,
they probably calculated that it would
be less risky to just block me from
entering then having me go in and show
the horrors and the abuses that are
going on there.
But I mean we're talking about executing
children and s sniper scopes and there's
videos of these soldiers gleefully
laughing.
They are literally like,
man,
did you see his legs go up?
Like look at that shit man out.
You get a headshot.
IDF soldiers have tee shirts where they
have pregnant women in crosshairs.
It says one shot,
two kills.
Like these people are fucking sick.
Yeah.
Yes there is.
Look it up.
IDF soldier,
pregnant women tee shirt.
They also have cross hairs of a babies.
Um,
yeah.
And then,
and then not only that,
but on top of all of this happening,
you have colonial settlers who come down
and they're cheering them on.
They're like,
this is the best show in town.
They're sitting there drinking coffee
and beer and just cheering on this
massacre that's been going on for four
weeks.
Okay.
There it is.
I want to shot to kills.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So to stand with us,
that organization,
that is a crazy fucking tee shirts.
Yeah.
So stand with us and all these other
organizations that work on the behalf of
the Israeli government to try to smear
anyone who criticizes it.
Your time is up,
man.
People are waking up.
You can't just keep executing people on
camera and getting away with it.
And you know,
if stand with us means stand with the
snipers shooting kids from a sniper
scope,
why are they doing this?
They want to terrorize and put fear in
the hearts of these people.
They don't want them to protest.
They want them to sub submit,
they want them to submit and they want,
they basically have dehumanize them to
the point where they,
you know,
you can't,
you can't put a kid in a sniper scope
and kill him unless you are.
You have completely dehumanized them to
the point where you think that he's an
animal.
Um,
and that's just,
that's just how it works.
I mean there had been so dehumanized
there.
It's not even funny.
And what these people are asking is,
is very simple.
They want the right to return,
which is authorized by the UN.
When the refugees were expelled in 1948
715 turned to Israel,
the right to return to Israel and live
as equal citizens.
It's not about,
you know,
a ball like it's not about expelling the
Jews or people who live there.
It's about living and coexisting and
having equal rights.
Because right now there is an apartheid
state where there's 50 discriminatory
laws within Israel proper.
Not to mention the fact that the
Westbank sender,
Israeli military law not dimension the
fact that Gaza is an open air prison.
So within Israel proper there's
apartheid too.
So it's,
it's sick.
We are sponsoring this with $10 million
a day is real,
would not survive without the US,
which is why I focused on ending the u s
empire.
Cause I'm like,
it doesn't matter if everyone in the
world boycotts Israel,
we're still going to subsidize the
whores and the daily atrocities with our
tax dollars and they're not going to
stop.
And that's why this is so fucking
brazen.
Wow.
Have we been vindicated,
Joe?
Because I can't think of another.
I mean what else have,
has anyone done something this brazen?
Committing an ongoing massacre for a
month straight.
Just sniping people who are completely
on an armed.
This is insane.
The only thing I can think of that's
slightly similar is when Israeli
commandos hijack that boat,
there was a flotilla going to Gaza to
bring wheelchairs because they don't
allow wheelchairs in.
That can be construed as a weapon.
Even though there's done tons of
amputees.
There was a boat going with aid workers
and they were bringing aid supplies and
commandos jumped on the ship like
helicopter down and just started
executing like people humanitarians that
we're going to bring Gaza aid.
And the news made it seem like there
were,
they were like,
look at these people on the boat,
like hitting them with chairs and stuff.
It's like,
dude,
they fucking propelled onto the boat and
started executing people.
Of course you're going to use whatever
you can to try to like ward off these
soldiers.
So that's the only other thing and that,
and that really woke me up to the whole
situation is when I saw how the media
was covering that massacre.
So now seeing this,
um,
I don't know how they're getting away
with it.
I don't know how people have not woken
up to this,
but the media,
the way that they're covering it is
atrocious.
They're saying there's clashes there
saying that the Palestinians are dying
of head wounds.
It's like,
no,
just say that they were executed with
sniper scopes.
Like this is deliberate.
Um,
but the way that the media plays around
and uses this passive voice is just not
just whether it's Palestine,
Venezuela's,
Syria.
Whenever you have like complete,
complete media uniformity,
just peddling align,
probably the truth is somewhere on the
other side,
what is,
what is Israel want?
But as a state,
like what do they want from the
Palestinians?
What do they expect?
They expect to just keep the status quo.
Keep business going as usual.
Never let those people live a normal
life.
Like what did,
what do they and why do they have so
much hate and why?
Why haven't the Israeli people like
seeing the horrors of this and rebelled?
Well,
to be a leftist in Israel,
it's,
it's difficult.
And to be an anti Zionist,
it's even more difficult because you're
rejecting your entire,
like I know religion as well as your
political identity.
Look,
it's a settler colonial state,
just like,
um,
a lot of other,
uh,
things in,
in the past.
But this is different because it's
ongoing.
And ever since the inception of Israel
to today,
the colonizers who colonized that land
always knew that there was an indigenous
Arab population that they wanted to kill
or expel.
Um,
and that's still the goal.
Like from Ben Gurion himself,
the,
the original,
you know,
prime minister of Israel.
I mean,
he said there's so many Arabs here when
you do expel them and take them there
places.
So it was never a land without a people
and a people without a land.
It was always overrun with Arabs and
they've always just wanted to expel the
indigenous population so they can have
an ethno supremacist state.
And that's really what it,
what it is.
And that's how can you be,
I'm sorry,
but can you be a Muslim and live in
Israel?
Can you be a Muslim and live in
Jerusalem?
Yeah.
But you,
but there's so many discriminatory laws
that are,
that basically it's an apartheid state
for non Jews.
Like in what way?
Like what are the laws that,
um,
I mean there,
there's so many things that,
that people can check out,
but um,
I would really recommend the work of
[inaudible] and Ronny Bark in there to
anti Zionist Israeli born Jews who have
extensively talked about this.
Um,
but I mean,
just,
just in the roads,
like there's settler only roads compared
to Palestinian only.
Yeah.
Compared to Palestinian roads.
People have different license plates,
you have different ID cards.
Um,
so if you are segregated schools,
like just all that stuff.
So you can't go to regular school.
No,
you can,
but,
but it's so segregated and hostile and
you're so indoctrinated from an early
age to basically hate these people and
think of them as the other.
And,
and I encourage everyone to check out
interviews that I did with,
with just average Israelis in the
streets because the genocidal rhetoric
is very apparent and it's very open and
these people weren't talking to anybody
right now.
Sure.
Yeah.
Checkout Abby Martin,
uh,
Israelis,
candid,
candid interview with Shirley.
One Opinion of that situation before you
went there and then a different one
after you came back.
Well,
I didn't even know what Palestine was
until I was 18 years old.
So when people say,
Oh,
you're only telling us one side of the
story,
look,
I didn't know the Palestine side of the
story until I was an adult,
which really you should say something
about our education system and our media
when you completely obfuscate an entire
reality.
And our only told one side.
Um,
but before I went there,
I,
you know,
I had a conception of what it was,
but once you go,
you really see how much worse it is.
So this is really party approves
annexation plan.
Um,
sorry,
I lost it.
Um,
is this the yeah.
Yeah.
So go to coerce Palestinian departure.
Go,
go forward like a a minute or two.
Go forward.
Two minutes.
Yeah.
These people after this,
keep going.
Keep going.
And what do you ask you?
Okay,
this is good too.
Okay.
So,
so I got to start playing here.
Um,
so I,
this is the thing and also the stand
with us.
People in the Israeli lobby basically
said,
oh,
you cherry picked these interviews.
You only picked like genocidal people to
talk to you.
What the hell you're talking about.
I was in Jerusalem as a place called
tolerance square is a bustling shopping
area.
I spoke to people from all backgrounds,
all walks of life and I just asked them
very simple questions.
What does it like to live here?
How do you deal with the,
you know,
problems.
Um,
and basically they just were very,
very readily like comfortable to tell me
very crazy genocidal things on camera.
Like no thinking that that would
actually look good for an American
audience.
So keep that in mind out.
A lot of people are sympathizing with
the Palestinian plight.
Um,
can you talk about what it's like to
kind of live in this situation?
Uh,
first of all it's very hard.
I also am an er visit or good position.
It's cooled lava against the Jews
shouldn't marry Arabs called it.
Did you say the organization was,
did what again,
we,
there,
there is the,
the thing of it is tone.
The Jews shouldn't marry Arabs shouldn't
marry Arabs.
Why do you feel strongly about that?
Because Jews is his special relation
that God give it to the Jews and Jews to
get mixed up together with a different
nation.
I think
Israelis I have to take over and uh,
they have to kick them or kicked him
away.
It will be much better
not to,
not to kill them,
just to,
to go back to,
to Arab countries as if they didn't lose
their people.
There's no need to try it.
There's no need to talk to them.
What we can do is one that they,
they do enough harm.
We retaliate.
That's war.
And that's the situation that any Jew
lives in Israel has to deal with.
Okay.
The Arabs,
nobody name and memory
obliterated.
It's about to get really crazy.
He killed terrorists.
They'd be afraid to cause any more
trouble,
then I'll be fine.
There'll be in their villages,
Morgan here,
we don't have to live together and
everything will be just fine.
Yeah.
Every Arab that doing a terrorism
attack,
Eh,
we have to kill him.
And not because it's an Arab,
because he's a terrorist.
Think he should,
uh,
also kick out the family because it's
all begins with the I saying the,
he's wearing a sons of anarchy tee shirt
by the way,
which is just so strange.
The kids does,
you know,
it's families.
I made that decision.
Okay,
how do you kick out the Arab?
They're getting a mini Manila.
Come on,
tell me the words.
I don't know.
She's like,
You can click translate.
She doesn't want to say it Jesse.
Really well.
I think we should give them a country.
If you're doing any problem,
you just going there to give them a
country and then it's going to be a war
between countries.
You know,
if they gonna throw rockets,
we're going to throw one big one and
done.
I don't think there's any answers.
Insane.
There's only one way I would carpet bomb
them.
It's the only,
it's the only way you could deal with it
or try to stop them a different way.
It never worked.
You mean all Arabs are Gaza or
I I believe that the like,
I hope to believe that are there or not,
but I do think they are because I never,
I don't,
I don't trust them.
One more thing.
Do you want to coming up and that's the
only way I believe that the only,
the only way is just to stop it
completely.
I'm things that day we miserable that
they Arab,
he say make it big.
We amen
these terrorists.
A tiny to killer.
She's laughing
with friends like,
uh,
all right,
have a good day.
We'll talk about this later.
This is reflected in polls.
A lot of people,
when you look at Israeli society,
you know,
it started off as kind of a socialist
project with the Kubota is,
and now it's just turned into a fascist,
a supremacist state where Netanyahu
reflects the true face of Israel.
Just like trump rep reflects the true
face of,
of this country.
And when it's getting too toxic for even
Natalie Portman to be,
uh,
you know,
this ambassador to Israel,
you know that the tide is turning.
But unfortunately there's so much shit
going on.
Congress hasn't said anything.
They just totally support this man.
And there's weird like bds legislation
trying to criminalize basically descent
where you have contractors in Texas
having to sign clauses,
promise that they won't support boycott
of Israel to in order to rebuild
hurricane homes.
What is bds?
Boycott divestment sanctions.
It's the movement that Palestinians have
asked us to help them to boycott.
And,
and that's what Stephen Hawking was all
about.
He,
he,
he boycotted,
um,
scientific conferences in Tel Aviv.
So this is what we gotta do.
And we have to fight our government to
stop endorsing these massacres in the
atrocities.
Obviously this attitude that these
people have,
it's coming from a place and they were
talking about terrorist attacks,
like how many terrorist attacks are
actually happening in Jerusalem or in,
in Austria.
You look at,
if you look at the breakdown of
terrorist attacks,
how many are guns,
soldiers?
And that really gives you an insight.
Look,
these people are being occupied
militarily.
The occupation is illegal under
international law.
Um,
and resistance is a lot of times
acceptable under international law when
you're being illegally occupied.
So you looking at terrorist attacks
against their look,
not many.
Um,
and when you look at the actual amount
of people who,
when you look at those tears of docs and
see how many are against soldiers,
like how many stabbing and techs are
against soldiers,
the numbers become very different.
Don't you think it's a,
it's a bit different in Israel and
they're more unified because the fact
that mandatory military service,
it's totally so everyone is,
if soldiers are attacked,
citizens are attacked.
They're all the same thing.
Everyone is a soldier in Israel.
Uh,
essentially,
well,
no.
A lot of these are like aren't armed
soldiers that are
right.
But I'm saying everyone identifies with
them because they have to do military
time.
Yup,
Yup.
That's the same thing with South Korea.
There's places that have mandatory
military service.
They have a totally different idea and
concept of nationalism.
So they feel like if,
if a military base got attacked in the
United States,
we would think damn soldiers got
attacked.
We wouldn't necessarily think of it the
same way is if say Dallas got attack
someone,
a terrorist attack happened in Dallas,
we would think of it as an attack on
American citizens.
Not just military,
but their military is their citizens
because mandatory military service.
Yeah.
And what's really weird is during the
last massacre in Gaza in 2014,
like half of the Israeli soldiers that
died were American.
Because that's what colonial,
that's what the colonial settlers are.
They,
they go over there from New Jersey and
they just post up and top of nerve
village and this is what's happening.
I mean it's off of the soldiers that
died.
Where is our consultants?
A lot of them where,
I'm not actually sure about that
statistic,
but I remember a lot where I was like,
why are so many Americans going over
their 17 year olds in joining the IDF?
I mean how bizarre is that?
What kind of mentality do you have to
have to move from like a comfortable
suburban Philadelphia to go like move on
top of an Arab village and he's ass.
These Jewish people that are doing this?
Yes.
No,
that want to go back to the motherland.
Yeah,
that's a huge,
there's always this desire to go to the
motherland.
Like it's such a tribal thing,
you know,
the purest form of the,
the conflict,
right?
Like that's types the Wailing Wall and
yeah.
I mean that's the spot,
right?
It's the epicenter of conflict too.
That's why it's so sad that so many
Palestinians can ever go to Jerusalem,
which is,
uh,
one of their holiest sites is there and
their band,
because again,
they're banned from everything.
So,
so if you're a Palestinian and you live
in Gaza,
you just,
you're just stuck.
You're stuck forever.
And that's why these people are like,
people from America,
they're like,
why that,
you know,
that's why you have this mantra like,
oh,
they want to die.
They raise their kids to be suicide
bombers know when you're in Gaza,
you are born dead.
You don't have a life.
So that's why these people are giving up
their lives to send a message to us.
That's why they're doing this.
That's the only reason they're doing
this is to send a message to us,
help us.
That's all they can do is use their
bodies.
So their concern is if they open up
Gaza,
the idea is that if the Palestinians
come and they live in Israel with
everybody else,
that they're just going to cause trouble
and kill people and create suicide
bombs.
And
that's,
that's what,
that's what they say.
Even though when I and and and the
Israeli lobby and the stand with us and
all these people have said,
you know,
you're,
you're portraying us as as really
different than we really are cause they
like to portray themselves as peaceful,
loving democratic nation.
And they were like,
Palestinians will say the same thing
about us.
Not True.
I was driving around and subtler plates
in a car that looked like I was a
colonial settler.
I did not hear one person say anything
remotely.
Genocidal about Jewish people I talked
to you look like cheesy.
Yeah,
you could fit right in.
I fit right in.
Just move on top of an Arab village.
I mean it's nuts and thank you for
letting me talk about this because it is
difficult to talk about it and I'm sure
it wasn't easy to get hundreds of of
emails telling you to denounce me and
all that other stuff.
We've been friends for a long time.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
I'm not denouncing and you know it's
coming from somewhere coordinated.
But that's a thing.
There's a lot of money behind these
attack campaigns
and I understand their perspective.
If they don't have the same experience
that you've had being over there and I
mean there's a lot of people over here
that are extremely loyal to Israel that
have never stepped foot in Israel.
Totally.
You know,
and maybe they haven't experienced what
you've experiment,
not maybe most likely.
It's just terrifying to me.
Forget about whether it's Israel or
Palestine,
forget about what it is.
The,
the idea that people could be stuck born
stock in this spot and really have no
recourse and not know where to go and
just be thought of by people that live
just a few miles away from you.
You're a subhuman and that the fact that
someone can make that t shirt with one
bullet,
two kills and show a pregnant woman with
cross hairs on her belly.
That scares the shit out of me.
That's,
that is Nazi Germany.
I mean the,
the fact that they can understand that
this treatment of the Palestinians in
that tee shirt is essentially the same
way the Nazis were looking at the choose
is treating people as the other.
It's a very difficult to understand
quality of human psychology is that when
we're in conflict with another nation,
another person,
we think of them as less than us,
like literally less human,
not human.
The enemy there,
that thing that we have to stop and it's
been a part of warfare since the
beginning of time.
Absolutely.
That's what's so trippy to me about like
the British occupation of Ireland
because these,
I don't know if you've seen that movie,
the wind that shakes the barleys.
Holy Shit.
I mean it's just nuts because I can see
like the conflicts around the world and
you know,
the other ism is usually someone who
looks different than you and,
but this is like all white dudes who
like all speak the same language and
they're just massacring each other.
Yeah.
I was in Belfast a few years back
show out there and after the show we
went outside and the cars,
the police cars,
they looked like they were in the
craziest fucking war zone you'd ever
seen.
The first of all,
the entire thing,
the front of the car was completely
covered in thick steel.
They had this big steel grate over the
windshield.
They are bomb like bomb shielding all
over the car.
We were looking at the cop car,
we're like,
what the fuck is this?
Like,
Oh yeah man,
this is when the IRA was bombing.
This is what they did.
They just started setting everything up
like this.
And we were talking to this driver in
the driver was explaining to us what it
used to be like when,
you know,
they were at war and what people had
done to people that knew him and you
know,
just people that look incredibly similar
to each other.
Again speaking the same language,
just gutting each other in the street,
torturing each other,
killing each other,
protestants versus Catholics.
I mean it's that thing that humans do
where they treat an enemy as something
less than them the other and just decide
that that's the red team and we're the
blue team.
So fuck them.
That that is a scary,
creepy fucking thing that humans are
capable of.
I'm not really,
yeah,
I'm confused about the whole religious,
um,
like how it grew into a religious
conflict.
Because originally it was just the
British colonial overlords,
like harassing the fucking beating the
hell and raping women to her,
just Irish and these villages and towns
and you know,
how much can you subjugate other people
and put them in cages like in Gaza or do
this and harass them and humiliate them
and told they'd do something about it.
I mean that's just the nature of human
beings.
You can't cage people well if anybody
wants.
If you really want peace on earth,
the Wa,
I mean is that really possible?
First of all,
right?
There's always a question like we're so
tribal and people are so committed to
their side and then their team and is it
ever possible to eliminate all war,
but the first step has got to be you.
We have to be able to identify with
those people and see their plight and
understand,
put yourself in their position.
If you are born in Gaza,
if you were born,
you know in Northern Ireland,
in back when the war was going on,
if you were born and big pickups,
pick a spot where there's a conflict.
You've got to be able to realize like we
got lucky.
You got lucky.
We got lucky.
We live in California.
You've got lucky.
I got lucky.
I was born in New Jersey.
We got lucky.
We're not in Gaza.
We're not where,
wherever it is,
wherever the conflict is,
if you can't see that,
if you've blocked off that aspect of
your perception that that is,
this is a classic trait that human
beings have exhibited since probably the
beginning of tribal life to be getting
of like organized groups of people
living together in a community,
fighting against all outsiders and so
almost like ingrained in our DNA,
the way we stay alive is anybody who is
outside of us.
Fuck them.
Well,
like you said,
we're only two people ago.
Literally like,
yeah,
that's how crazy.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Three people to go,
we had slaves.
Yeah.
Three people go.
People have to be a hundred it.
Yeah.
That's real.
I mean that and no one says that.
You know,
they don't look at it like human beings.
We,
we rely on information,
right?
We rely on like,
oh,
that's what's going on.
Oh,
I didn't know.
You know,
like [inaudible] most of us don't know.
You're just driving in your car or
you're doing your life.
You,
you're really not getting information
from all over the globe.
How many people accurately even
understand why North Korea hates us so
much and what do the amount of fucking
shit we dropped on them during the war?
20% of their population.
Yeah.
Percent.
Imagine millions of Americans is that,
and we're like,
ah,
that Wacky Kim John Boone,
he's fucking haircut.
You hear what he did?
He's crazy.
He has Dennis Rodman comes over there.
They played basketball.
I mean,
that's literally most people,
that's the extent of their understanding
of why North Korea distrust the United
States.
After we decimated the entire country,
all the infrastructure drop napalm over
the entire country where we actually
retreated only because there was no
infrastructure left to bomb.
And for the past,
I don't know,
70 years,
North Korea has literally been building
up defenses to,
to prepare for the next time that they
know that that will happen.
And we're like,
oh my God,
there's the one,
I'm crazy.
Look at this crazy military fascist
state.
It's like,
well,
I mean,
there's a reason behind all these
things.
They don't happen in a vacuum.
I was reading an article today about how
their nuclear test site is imploding.
Like they've blown up so much over there
that the fucking grounds caving and
they're opening up a portal of the hell.
Like,
I like to blow a hole through the earth,
but something really good could come out
of it with the peace talks,
president moon of South Korea and Kim
Jong noon.
And now trump is forced to,
to jump on board.
And if trump can can pull this off,
then more power to them.
Man,
that's gotta be so strange to North
Koreans and South Koreans looking
exactly the same,
staring at each other across the lawn.
You know,
back when I was competing and taekwondo,
it was,
uh,
you know,
Koreans are extremely nationalistic and,
uh,
the South Koreans and the North Koreans,
you know,
they would occasionally compete in North
Korea.
It was,
you know,
it's gotta be so bizarre to think that
if you zigged you for your ancestor
zigged instead of zagged,
if you were born like 50 miles that way
you'd be North Korean and you'd be stuck
under the ruling of this fucking wacky
son.
And instead you're over here making
Samsung phones,
you know?
Well,
for the first couple of decades,
South Korea was ruled by dictators who
were just as crazy.
So this whole like,
oh were we weren't friends with him
because of him being a dictator.
It's like,
no,
you're just,
we're trying to,
you know,
the whole,
well,
we supported one side and the side we
supported makes kickass electronics and
they're addicted to plastic surgery.
Have you seen what they're doing with
women's eyes over there?
No.
Oh my goodness.
Women in South Korea,
it's so common that they get their eyes
done.
They get their eyes done,
like an anime character was like white
and cut their lids cut and pulled up so
that they have these giant Western eyes
but exaggerated and it's so common that
it like if you didn't know any better,
you would think that this is like,
oh well some people look like this.
There's so much plastic surgery over
there that it's extremely common for
these women to get these weird fucking
eyes.
Jamie CD,
you pull it up because uh,
this is something that I became aware
of.
She's is,
I want to say like eight or nine years
ago when I was like,
I just thought it was just a girl that
looked like that.
Like that's not even a good example that
that girl still looks Asian.
That's a boy.
Like look what they're doing there.
They're westernizing their eyes,
but there's some,
there's some really good,
that guy got his job done.
He looks better on the right now.
Like that one.
That's a good example.
You see what they're doing.
It's like they're doing this strange
thing with their eyes or their making
their eyes larger.
Yeah.
But it's extremely common and whitening
cream is,
yeah,
see they're,
they're changing their eyes before,
after.
Yay.
Look,
that's so much more eye lashes.
Well,
I wonder what was going on.
I see this girl.
That's painful.
Yeah,
I'm sure it sucks,
but afterwards she gets so much more
Dick.
I mean it's,
I wonder,
first of all,
I wonder why genetically their eyes are
like that.
That's interesting to think of like
what,
like we know that the reason why people
in England and Ireland and in this
northern climates like why they became
so pale,
they became so pale because they had a
very strong lack of vitamin D because
there was no sun,
the air.
So there they basically like a reflector
for the sun.
They tried to absorb as much sun as
possible because they live in this
cloudy area as opposed to our great,
great ancestors lived in Africa.
And that's,
that's literally why white people exist.
We're just Africans with the lack of
vitamin D.
So racism as a construct.
Oh fuck.
Most certainly is.
But it's also observable,
right?
Like,
like there's a clear ancestral origin to
certain body types and diets.
Like there's certain people that live in
parts of West Africa,
they're just fucking phenomenal runners
and there's no denying that there's
certain traits that people have that you
can clearly say.
I think the real problem is when we say
race,
like the real prime and then that gets
us tribal again.
That's us versus them again,
because it's just humans.
It's just humans that that's there.
It's one race.
But humans that live in high altitude
climates that are much more adapted to
low oxygen environments.
Humans that live in like the inuits that
live in extreme cold climates and have
no access to vegetables,
they adapt to this specific fat rich
diet.
Their hands are less likely to get cold.
They actually developed like a genetic
predisposition to,
uh,
for their,
their ability to withstand cold with
their hands.
Like we would go over there and we
fucking,
our hands would be normally
be like,
fuck,
fuck.
And they would just be like playing
piano and shit.
Like it wouldn't even bother them like
this.
This is genetic.
I mean,
this is because their bodies have
adapted.
But there one race,
it's just humans are malleable.
We're super flexible,
you know?
And we could,
you could see that in your lifetime,
right?
I mean,
if someone works out,
they develop more muscle that gets
stronger.
And then there's the concept of
epigenetics and the,
the possibility that some of these
traits and some of these learned
behaviors you're passing onto your
children through genes.
So you see an animal planet.
What do we mean the,
what is it a show?
It's a show that it shows how,
um,
animals and the symbiotic relationship
between humans and animals.
It's really insane.
And there's a whole [inaudible] section,
but there's like,
you know,
tribes and the jungle and stuff who will
work with birds to get beehives and the
birds will get the reward and get some
money.
And then if you,
and then if you don't give them any
honey,
then they'll trick you and take you to
like,
I'm not beehive tree.
I mean there's just,
it's just nuts.
And then helping humans fish and man
blue planet two is also fuck fucking
nominal.
You have.
You would love it,
dude.
There's an optimist who makes a sea
shell suit.
He literally makes it suit of armor out
of shells to block themselves from a
shark.
It's nuts.
One super nuts.
Yeah.
Animals are huge.
I mean,
they're weird and we're,
we're,
we're animals.
We don't like to think we are because we
can talk and sing songs and Shit and get
her eyes done,
but we're,
we're animals and some sort of strange
way.
We're the same as trump.
Yeah.
Do you see the big boxy suits somehow?
He's got a good ass Taylor man.
Well,
look,
obese is the trump statute.
Jamie and I were talking about it
yesterday in the,
which was it?
The presidential house of wax or some
show?
No.
Does anyone please tell me it's bad.
It's crazy.
It's like punking him.
No Way.
That's great.
Do you ever seen a little bit,
let me look at it though.
Good.
Make that larger so he could see what it
looks like.
Operation Fuck trump.
Trump debuts at Disney world,
but I'm telling you,
it doesn't look anything like him.
Like,
if I was the person who created,
look,
that's George Washington seems normal.
But look at the trump one.
Wait,
like,
what in the fuck is that?
It doesn't look anything like him.
Oh God,
look at it.
So to Jamie,
he looks like he's like 20 years older
than he is.
Doesn't even look like him.
I mean whoever that artist is like he's
gotta be punking him is,
this is no way.
He liked did some weird shit to his jaw.
His jaws like extended and creepy.
He made his neck skin is the same
artists that did the Chris John Rowe,
not Chris Johnno,
Renaldo,
uh,
bust.
You saw that right?
He looks pretty much the same.
And so you didn't find a photo of it
because in high res photos is a low res
video.
It's difficult to see how shitty it is.
But it's so shitty that it looks fake.
Like,
like no,
this is not really the one.
No.
The one,
they fucking commissioned an artist and
this is the artist's creation.
Whereas this animatronic wax museum,
I don't know,
but I'm going over is in Disney world,
Disney land.
So inbred looking.
Um,
do you think they,
you're looking bread.
Eric Trump.
He looks odd.
He looks like he has no upper like look
at that.
Come on.
Oh my God.
That's what we're talking him.
Good.
But either way,
good or bad.
This is clearly a little bow.
Does that if Hillary,
no,
do not tell me that.
No.
Okay.
This is the fire.
This guy who did the Obama one,
this terrible.
They just saw I could do better than
that.
And that's fucking knocked off wax
museum.
Look how bad that is.
If it doesn't look anything like him.
Oh God.
It's great that they can do like Jeff
for sin and Lincoln and all that stuff.
Cause all they had was drawings.
No,
terrible.
Yeah,
it's pretty bad.
I don't know how we got onto that.
Oh,
humans malleable humans.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm hoping,
you know,
just like slavery doesn't exist anymore
in the United States,
at least.
I'm hoping that as time goes on there's
going to be less tribalism and that as
human beings are able to freely travel
and communicate with each other,
we're going to be dealing with less of
this.
But isn't it sad that it seems like it's
almost getting worse even though we have
all the information available at our
fingertips,
we're still like,
we just elected someone who basically
got famous politically because he said
Obama was a secret Muslim and Kenyon
people love hearing that Shit.
They love hearing that shit and they
don't want to hear anything differently.
Do you know what's going on right now?
But she yeti coolers and the NRA?
No.
It's fascinating because this just shows
how tribal and crazy people get yeti
coolers.
They canceled some,
they had these programs like go to go
to,
uh,
do you know my friend Ben O'brien's
instagram?
Do you know that?
Yeah,
I put it on Adam Green trees and we'll,
we'll,
we could read it,
but what,
what Yeti did,
they discontinued these Africa,
what they,
the way they describe,
describe the program,
but they had a bunch of outdated um,
incentive programs where like,
you know,
like if you signed up for something and
get a discount,
like a discounted program,
here it is,
this cow outdated discounting program
and Yeti makes super high end coolers.
They're like really expensive,
but they literally will keep ice for
days.
You could put ice in them and go to the
desert and five days later you have ice
in that cooler.
And I'm not bullshit fucking phenomenon.
That's exactly what to do with it.
Phenomenal.
So anyway,
they notified the NRA and the
organization has changed.
Getty explained to them that they're
offering an alternative customization
program broadly available to consumers
and organizations,
including the NRA foundation.
So then the NRA releases this statement
that Yeti coolers doesn't want to work
with the NRA anymore.
They don't support the second
amendment's of fuck them.
So people start blowing up their yeti
coolers.
Just like that Karen coffee maker,
they filled the Yeti coolers up with
that thermite shit.
Or what did,
what does that stuff not thermite?
What's that explosion of Shit?
Stephen Paddock had a bunch of that shit
in his car.
Um,
what does that cricket not whatever the
day is that what it is?
And yeti support is blown up.
Yeti coolers.
Yes.
It's all done.
Let's look at [inaudible]
coolers.
You can suck my Dick.
I'm American.
So they filled it out with this
explosive shit.
And by the way,
these coolers are fucking expensive.
There's super engineered and you know,
they start at like 300 bucks a so this
is looking at their blow.
This,
I'm telling you,
these people are just looking for an
excuse to blow shit up.
But there's a great quote in this
article.
What does this article from,
what does this website,
this is the Washington Post and nuts.
Um,
there's,
there's a great quote in this article
that sort of highlights how fucking
preposterous this all is.
It's all me.
I don't think it's The Washington Post
babies stability.
It's good.
God,
but I don't think it's that.
What I really think is that they want an
enemy.
They're happy when something happens.
And even though Yeti's explained,
know their whole fucking business is
hunters and fishermen and anglers,
they're not anti NRA.
They're definitely not anti second
amendment like fucking relaxed.
So even after they put out that
statement,
the NRA doubled down and released
another statement.
You know,
you made a big mistake and now you're
paying for it.
I really think we have a real problem
and especially there's a real problem in
that regard because they need to
understand everybody don't understand
that we should all anybody that supports
any outdoor activities has to understand
that the conflict,
if you have any internal conflict
against each other,
like,
but the thing about hunters and
fishermen,
all these people,
what their real opposition is is animal
rights activists and radical Animal
Liberation Organization type people.
That's the real enemy.
The enemy isn't Yeti coolers,
who makes their business selling shit to
hunters and fishermen and anglers.
Like these people are crazy.
So this conflict just shows to me like
people are just looking for a fight
right?
Like,
right.
You know how long it takes to get all
that fucking explosive shit and put it
in a cooler.
This is just happened.
And these got,
we're ready.
Camera Ready.
Got To put this up on facebook.
I need to get some likes there.
Boom.
And they're blowing up these fucking
$300.
$500 cooler is good.
Easy by and buy him up.
Yeah.
But now these,
this also is really fascinating.
Yeah.
I'll,
I'll send this to Jamie because I sent
it to her friend Ben.
Oh,
Brian,
who's freaking out about this because
Ben is,
uh,
he's,
he's an executive at Yeti.
My Buddy Ben,
and you know,
I sent him this thing where all these
other coolers,
um,
all these other cooler companies are
freaking out and jumping in and saying,
we are all second.
It's on deadspin here.
Jamie.
I'll send it to you right now.
One of these people will kill me.
All these alt right.
I mean,
I don't know if they're all right.
So I've,
all right.
A lot of people
who say,
you know liberals are snowflakes and you
and you cry,
but everything,
it's like,
dude,
you guys are literally have built
careers off being victims.
I mean,
what is happening here?
I mean I know that this is not exactly
the same thing,
but it kind of is ridiculous.
Now.
You think protest,
you throw your care coffee maker out,
smash it with a bat.
Well that's Sean Hannity.
He speaks the truth and he's got damn
lippers.
We'll trying to silence the truth and
I'm not having it from Keurig.
You on a blood cot.
Sean Harris.
I'm going to point you like the Laura
Ingram thing was fascinating.
Here it is.
Bison coolers.
Look at these people and we tap lag.
If you have a second amendment supporter
company,
we love guns and joining the herd it
says,
look at that.
Joined the herd.
How about joining the herd?
What?
Join the herd of sheep.
Fuck.
You're trying to get people to be sheep,
like join the herd.
What do you,
why would you say heard or people
cattle.
You write crazy asshole.
Speaking to an audience.
There's a great quote in that.
Scroll down a little bit,
Jamie.
Scroll down a little bit because of the
second amendment like here it is.
Scroll down to scroll down so I could
read that.
Bottom texts has,
so here we find ourselves in the midst
of a dumb as rocks arm race between
essentially indistinguishable cooler
blend brands all trying to declare their
undying devotion to guns more fervently.
Then their rivals.
The whole shit is exactly as stupid as
it seems.
And amid the fog of marketing bullshit
and bad faith NRA posturing,
there's one truth that none of this can.
None of this mess can obscure 479 99 is
too much to pay for a cooler.
I disagree because there's solid fucking
coolers.
They're,
they're very,
they're worth it.
If you can keep it here,
using it for what you're using it.
If you go hunting or camping,
you can keep fucking dairy important to
me.
It does.
Oregon's very insanely good coolers.
But who wrote that article?
Gives our guys fucking hilarious man.
The deadspin author hat trick.
Redford.
God brought us you Patrick.
Dumb as rocks quote.
Fucking so stupid.
Blown up.
Cool.
This is what our discourse has become.
It's like mass hallucinations on both
sides of the political aisle.
You're either a Russian Bot or a troll
or your,
everything's fake news and it's all,
you know,
q and on rapport,
your lip tartar,
snowflake.
It's,
let's talk about that other thing.
The Q and on thing.
No,
the guy who blew up,
or the guy who ran over those,
pia is what is the new word and soul.
What does the word soul,
soul incent.
Voluntary Celibate.
So people are killing people because now
bordain was tweeting that there's like
some sort of a rabbit reddit forum with
all these folks and there's like
$40,000.
Totally.
Well,
the guy who shot a bunch of women in
Santa Barbara a couple of years ago,
he was also like,
I'm so attractive.
Why don't you guys want to have sex with
me?
It's like,
look,
it doesn't matter what you look like.
There's healthy,
loving relationships that exist for
everyone.
Yeah.
He was acuity,
the little murder.
He was a little cutie.
So it's just crazy when people blame
women in are violent misogynists
because they are,
you know,
um,
on,
uh,
they think that they're unattractive and
they're basically just blame,
like attractive women for not having sex
with them.
It's really disturbing.
And this guy apparently mowed down a
bunch of people in Toronto because he,
he was one of these people
insoles creating rules.
And honestly the sickens me what,
this is the uh,
don't go down 70,000,
70,000 now,
but I think it was 40,000 yesterday.
So there's like a bunch of goofballs
that just signed up just to,
just to read to what the fuck's going on
over there.
Cause people are freaking out with the
idea that okay here it is.
Insult tears is a place for folks to
submit screenshots,
not direct links of crazy stuff posted
by self describing Oh okay.
This is,
this is the mocking way.
There's another one though.
There's another one that bordain was
quoting,
but it's fucking hard out there for a
pimp.
I get it.
But don't take a truck and run over a
bunch of civilians cause he can't get
laid.
Just choose the very classes that teach
people how to be nice,
so people like them,
man,
like there's those pickup artists type
guys who do like seminars and how to
pick people up.
Shouldn't it be like like,
Hey,
this is how it'd be a nice person,
right?
Like this is how you want what you want
a girlfriend.
Oh,
okay.
We got to be someone that people want to
be with.
Like,
yeah,
exactly.
How do you do that?
Some people don't know how to do it
right,
but just socially fucked up and
they live on reddit.
They don't leave their basement and this
is what comes out of it.
It's really unfortunate.
They need to interact with normal people
in society and realize that there's some
someone for everyone.
I mean,
you know,
not really though.
Maybe there.
All right.
You got to find an insole.
Women are there.
There's no insult.
Women.
Women can always get laid,
right.
There's no such something tells me
there's no insulin and well,
yeah.
You know,
I know that.
Yeah.
Did you hear about this term before?
I did not know about this term before,
no.
How many of these terms are out there
that we don't know about that are going
to blow up in our face.
Yeah,
right.
I mean,
that are going to commit massacres and
then we're going to have to find out
about some other weird subculture on
reddit that has been,
there's multiple of them.
So fucking weird time to be alive.
Like the weirdest,
I think in really insane.
I mean,
like I said before,
the mass hallucination is there's no way
to have actual dialogue or discourse
about reality because you're a Russian
Bot.
Yeah.
The liberals have not an a,
and I mean the liberals meaning the Neo
Liberal,
the think tank establishment that people
that people call leftists,
which is a misnomer.
But those people are so in denial about
the fact that trump won,
that they still just have to blame
Russia for the fact that trump is our
president.
They can't accept that he won
democratically.
No.
Um,
so it's really pathetic that now you
have them suing the DNC over this
erroneous fraudulent lawsuit that's
basically threatening press freedom.
They're basically saying,
if you publish leaks,
including trump's tax returns,
you could even say,
I mean this is what journalists do.
They publish things that are sure people
give them.
That's echoing economic espionage,
they said.
So this is like,
this has profound implications for press
and it's an incredible how desperate
they're,
they're slapping a lawsuit on Julian
assange choose still arbitrarily
detained in an embassy.
Yeah,
they cut off his internet.
So how's he get online?
He is not online.
He's,
they basically are trying to force him
out at this point.
And if they forced him out that just
going to jail him on trumped up charges
because they're trying to get them on
the sex charge.
But hasn't that sex charges been
dropped?
It was dropped.
There's a lot of weird things about it
initially.
I don't know.
Um,
you know,
all I know is that a son,
they basically said that they could not
promise that he won't be extradited to
the u s which means they will extradite
him to the U S and we've already had
palm peo,
who's the psychotic Koch brothers Shill
who just got appointed.
Um,
said he,
he wants to basically see Julian assange
go down.
I mean,
he had harsh words for Julian assange.
So even though trump talks out of both
sides of his mouth on the campaign,
he was like,
I love Wiki leaks.
He is going to prosecute him probably to
save his own ass.
And it pretend like he,
you know,
did he say,
I love wikileaks?
He actually did.
Yeah.
During the campaign he was like,
Julian Assange Bang and Pamela Anderson.
It looks like he did on Julian hindered.
Pamela Anderson brought him a bunch of
Chinese food to the crazier it gets
cray.
She can never fucking Julian his sons.
Yeah.
Promote Gateway Pundit.
That's disturbing.
But um,
what does that,
well,
remember the last time I was on,
you were like,
you brought up the whole pizzagate thing
and we were talking about,
of Julian assange has been,
I love Wiki leaks.
I think that he's trolling,
but it's an irresponsible trolling where
he's just kind of trying to stir shit.
I mean,
I don't know.
If I were joining us on,
who knows how I would feel being pushed
in an embassy.
And you know,
being arbitrarily detained,
like kind of not being able to leave,
looking at a shitty wrote.
Oh,
he must be going crazy.
I mean,
Julian assange literally must be going
crazy,
right.
But that the Internet,
the Internet was really what it was
saving him.
So now that Marino and look at all these
quotes.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
Came out.
Trump said wiki leaks.
I love Wiki leaks.
Wiki leaks.
I love you.
October,
2016 the wikileaks stuff,
it's unbelievable.
It tells you the inner heart.
You got to read it.
What?
This guy just flies by the seat of his
pants.
So full fucking hilarious.
I know this is prepared.
It's been amazing.
It's coming from wiki leaks and then
another one says another one come in
today trump said this.
Wikileaks is like a treasure trove.
Another one he says,
getting off the plane.
We just announcing new wikileaks and I
wanted to say there a that,
but I didn't want to keep you waiting.
Said trump.
Boy,
I love reading those Wiki.
This is hilarious.
Like let them go.
Then donald free.
Why don't you uh,
pardon him.
Pardon his ass.
Well,
why wouldn't he like,
I don't understand why he was because
he's a bullshitter.
He's a con artist and he's tricked
everyone into thinking that he's this
somehow anti deep state
antiestablishment guy and he's not,
um,
and joining us on,
you know,
if he pardons in and that's,
that's his undoing I think.
I think if anything he'll prosecute him.
Where's that girl that accused him of it
was surprise sex.
That's what she accused him of.
Like they had sex with a condom and in
the middle of the night
he had sex with her with no condom.
We didn't knock it in.
And in Sweden it's um,
I think they called it soprise sex does
that a new term.
But I mean,
how the fuck is that guy going to get
export to the United States because of
that?
How is he going to get deported sex by
surprise.
Oh six by surprise.
Well,
the next honeypot they need editors
because they should cut out a couple of
words there.
Yeah,
it's insane.
And meanwhile,
while trump is this like Internet troll
and he definitely is an Internet troll.
Meanwhile,
the evangelicals are taking the fuck
over all these fifth circuit court
judges that trump has appointed.
They're all like from the 16 hundreds
mentality is like 500 years old.
Like session scares the shit out of him.
Do sessions.
Devoss pence,
Palm Peo talks about the rapture all the
time.
When does it come in?
Does he have a knife?
I don't know man.
But they're all doing a self fulfilling
prophecy with Bolton at the helm.
I mean,
Jesus Christ with Bolton and Giuliani
and Nikki Haley and Paul [inaudible].
He's going to fix it.
It's going to come in and fix it.
They're deep state outsider.
This,
this mother fucker.
What is he supposed to do?
I don't know.
He's like,
he's supposed to like end the Mueller
probe and Mueller's like,
yeah,
yeah.
I'll be,
I'll get right on that bolden.
Shit.
So nuts though.
Cause it's like,
dude,
these people were way too crazy to even
be taken seriously during like the Bush
administration.
I mean,
they were the most psychotic outliers of
the Islamophobic.
Neo-Con wings where John Bolton's
writing op eds saying why we need to
attack North Korea first,
um,
why we need to bomb Iran bomb bomb bomb
Iran.
So Giuliani meets with Mueller and tries
to determine if he has an open mind.
And other headline I just saw says he's
sort of,
he's meeting with Mueller to see or to
negotiate a interview with trump.
Ah,
do you remember when?
Oh,
that's it.
So he's like the,
the middleman.
Remember when Giuliani was rocking the
comb over?
You think he talked to Donald?
Go Donald,
just shave it.
Look at me.
Donald on free corn free Chinese.
Three firms that make your headpiece.
He's got something wacky going on up
there.
The Taylor man's talking about it.
Call me,
was saying that it appears to all be
his.
And he goes,
and I will admit that I,
I gave it a good look
while he was,
while I was sucking his dick.
You saw the video of it float wells
combing.
Oh No,
call me.
Sorry.
I thought your time at Giuliani flowing
in the wind.
That was,
that was horrifying.
It was horrifying.
It didn't even look like it looked like
a demon with a trump suit on.
Oh God,
I can't.
That's all I actually can.
Oh God.
Like there's like a monsters on
like they dollum up a demon and the
trump suit.
Did you see Ivanka trump holding those
vials?
Like she was like trying to cure cancer.
She's like just just doing her biology
stuff and in the lab she do a lot of
that is testing some samples.
Diseases.
Yeah.
She fucking hates him so much.
She,
when he tries to hold her hand and she
like get away,
get away.
That's like this.
A bunch of clips like trying to hold
hands with her.
She's like,
nope,
there's a bug from her wearing the wacky
white hat and he's like,
come on,
hold my hand.
Hold on.
Nope.
What do it people watch it.
You get to hold my hand.
People watching.
It's so strange.
It's like,
that's like when cooper was like,
did you want to have sex with trump
here?
She was like,
no,
of course I didn't.
Oh Man.
Oh No.
I touch your hair.
I dyed your hen
trying to hit your head,
but he got it eventually.
Got It.
Shit.
You got it.
Did you see him?
Look at him?
God,
these people are really admiring her
because of her composure through all
this because she's not freaking out and
going crazy.
Well,
she's just kind of keeping it together
through all this.
I mean,
it's gotta be hard.
Yeah,
it is.
I mean,
fucking president after this guy,
like the scrutiny that he's been under
in whether he deserves it or not.
I'm not saying he doesn't,
but who the fuck would want that
microscope up your ass?
Yeah.
Who would want that?
I think it's an arrangement just like
him and stormy Daniels,
that she wanted a job in the
apprenticeship.
What I'm saying is like,
how will we going to get another
president like they're going to do you
know what the fuck they're gonna.
They're gonna look up Kanye his ass with
a microscope and he's going to go crazy
again.
He's gonna flip freak out and go to some
insane asylum.
Like,
he doesn't understand that he's saying,
he tweeted,
he was like,
does this look like the sunken place?
And it's just like his giant corridor in
his house and it's like,
I don't know dude.
I think you're liking from get out.
Cause that everyone's like,
dude,
you're in the sunken place.
You don't get out when he,
when he sinks down to the second place.
But he's like doubling down and he's
like,
does this look good?
The sunken place,
and it's like showing a baller house is
baller house in hidden hills,
which is like,
uh,
have you seen,
what does it mean?
Um,
mayweather?
Is that the guy's name?
His lawyer.
His,
uh,
instagram is unbelievable.
Dude.
He's great
wearing costumes and shit.
He's like,
I'm the joker.
And he's like,
dude,
it's not even Halloween.
What are you doing please?
I'm having fun.
Just running around with the time.
His life before traumatic brain injury.
Now,
just joking.
He doesn't even have brain injury.
It's fascinating about him because he's
such a good domestic.
Whoa,
look at that.
He's such a good defensive.
This is counting as the breadwinner.
It says he's just sitting there counting
dude,
there's a hilarious photo of him like
sitting in the middle of just this huge
empty room and he's just like,
I don't even know his find the Kanye
Soto Kanye.
He's a trip.
He really is a trip and he's,
he's,
whether he means to be or not,
he's a master at getting people to pay
attention to him,
whether it,
whether this is just because he's so
wacky that everybody's paying attention
to him or whether it's a real calculated
sort of maneuvered to act outrageous and
act like he's out of control.
But boys,
he fucking good at it.
Here it is.
It's like,
dude,
do you didn't have any furniture.
It was like bench at the end of this.
A weird ass hoe.
This look like in place and he's crying
laughing now it looks like this looks
like a table that kind of looks like
shit man.
You don't have really have good style
with a buck a whoa.
He's got a white torso in the
background.
Scroll up again,
but what does that torso in the
background?
What's that?
Kim's like,
actually,
can we just get it done out of here?
The waist is too thick.
Yeah.
Can,
can you give this thing Lipo a bigger
ass?
Give it a bigger ass.
So straight.
See us the car door.
A lot.
Like a parking garage or like what is
the long ass open space with white
walls?
Suck it.
Does this look like a sunken place?
Wow.
Fantastic.
Um,
babe,
we had a rule not to show our home,
so can we now allow K U W K to keeping
up with the Kardashians filming in the
home?
This is,
oh,
well.
So they're communicating only through
tweets.
She's like,
come home and take care of the kids.
They've been winning a fucking genius.
Wow.
Poor.
But I'm not here blowing minds.
Do you like how trump is so desperate
for attention that he was like,
cool.
Kanye.
Thank yeah.
He's like,
I love you.
I love your Cognac.
You,
Kanye.
I was talking about how I wanted Kanye
or not Kanye.
I wanted,
uh,
to,
to meet with trump,
to see if I could talk him into actually
fighting Joe Biden.
It's like you're a businessman.
You want to make that,
I'd be like,
you're,
you're the best at everything.
Could be the best at fighting.
Hey,
we're in a reality star culture.
Why not?
How much?
I don't,
first of all,
awesome Joe Biden's on death door.
All he has to do is have a stiff jab and
Joe Biden's going down,
he's fucked.
You know,
he could,
trump really could win.
It's take us just state,
just ramp up the diet pills,
choke him with the hairpiece.
Hairpieces fragile.
You can't.
So Dude,
last time I was on,
I was just about to go to Venezuela and
that was insane.
I went and embedded myself in the
protests there.
Holy Shit.
Is the media line about that too?
And then the line about their,
you know,
vices on the ground acting like bad
asses.
They're embedding themselves in the
protest and being like,
look at these fucking awesome dudes.
Um,
it was basically fascist mobs,
tried to lynn just and we got chased out
of the country and then our colleague
got shot because we dare to tell that,
um,
the death toll that we kept hearing in
the mainstream media,
that Maduro is mowing down all these
protesters,
we found out that the majority of the
dust are actually caused by the
protesters,
like either shooting people,
lynching people alive,
burning them alive,
or doing these giant roadblock cade's
where they would light giant flaming
piles of trash and people would be,
you know,
flying off the freeway or getting an
accidents and shit.
And so once we just reported those
facts,
then this lynch mob came after us.
It was very,
very scary.
And look,
I mean the media is lying about the
popular support that that Maduro's
government has.
Um,
there was massive program and rallies
there and the country's pretty divided
where it just depends on who you would
talk to.
So what does,
what does vice doing over there?
I mean,
is an imperial arm.
You should,
everyone should check out my brother's
documentary called the brazen imperial.
Oh Dude.
100% of the u s government,
Shane Smiths and imperial arms.
Smith,
welcome to Obama and Biden into their
office.
And they were like,
bff dude,
the coo of vice was like Obama's like
spokesperson.
I mean good friends with Shane.
I know him,
I know him very well.
I mean,
vice repeats.
He's not an imperial guy.
I'm saying they're lying.
They're lying.
The line not lying the line because they
look,
I think Obama and Biden are war
criminals.
So I don't think it's cool as a
journalist to not challenge power.
And so when you invite these people into
your office and are really buddy buddy
with them,
I'm offended by that.
You're such a radical lefty.
I love it.
It's trailing Obama and Biden,
a war criminals.
Even though the lefties,
even the lefties,
they drone King Babe.
Drone King.
Yeah.
There was definitely a lot of drone
desks,
but um,
check out a very heavy agenda.
And my brother's documentary just goes
over kind of a lot of stuff about vice.
But I think the problem that I have with
advice is,
is just like the problem that I have
with all,
all other corporate media,
like we were saying,
there's always a that's uniform that
basically promotes the u s empire and
promotes American exceptionalism.
So clearly you've never,
when you fuck,
that's delicious.
You know,
what is that best show on Vice
Eddie Wong's world?
Those two?
What's that?
Action Bronson is.
Fuck,
that's delicious.
That's his show.
You know,
Action Bronson has the rapper.
Oh Yay.
Yeah.
I haven't watched it.
Never had a human being come in the
studio and smoke more weed.
Never seen anybody smoke.
He'd just non stop.
We had an ashtray that we took photos of
it afterwards.
Like this is how much weed action
Bronson smoked while he was on the show.
I just ran into him the other day at the
UFC.
He smoked like how many joints?
10 joints.
Easily.
Big Ass joints.
Big Fat boys puffed him down to the NUB.
And we were,
we were with Jamie and I were stunned
where like,
how's he keep going?
That's on fights too.
Nice.
Does have a lot of good,
she got a lot of good Shim.
Is that when it comes to coverage,
a foreign policy,
I think they really missed the boat.
Well it's been good on like that's the
thing,
it's the,
it's still accept.
Um,
you know,
it's like anyone can kind of submit.
It's a kind of like Huffington Post.
It's like a huge
10.
I think they have a hard time filtering
everything out.
I think they've gotten,
you know,
they were this radical sort of like
upstart where people hadn't heard of
them before and they were doing wild
shit and they had some really cool
videos like,
like the guide to travel and they did
that thing where they went to Liberia
and met with general button naked and
he's explaining about eating children
and cutting their heart's fucking
insane.
So that was all shane.
Shane did a lot of that stuff.
That,
and that was the early days.
But that,
that's I,
I appreciate that,
that kind of style of journalism.
But I feel like what's missing is the
context behind it.
Like just vice will go to India and be
like,
fuck,
this is fucking nuts.
And you're like,
well why is there this massive
disparity?
And you know,
it qualities.
So it's a different style of journalism.
But I do think that they really missed
the boat on Venezuela,
Russia and Ukraine and some other things
when it comes to global conflicts
because that's just the problem with a
lot of journalism and corporate media in
general is that you're towing a line
because you're an American.
Just like we were talking about
Israelis.
I mean you have preconceived notions,
you have your own bias,
you have your own ethnocentric lens
about world issues.
So it bleeds over into those conflicts.
And unless you're like an
internationalist,
can you see the world from a different
Lens?
But when I was on the ground and
Venezuela,
I was like,
this is not what we're seeing.
So what do you think is happening in
Venezuela?
So what we,
I mean there,
there's a lot of things happening,
but the thing that the u s government
wants to obfuscate,
and that's why you see Venezuela
continues to come up all the time as
another country that needs to be taken
out and helped by US interests,
right?
Because they haven't bowed down to us.
Economic Agenda,
Gemini,
it's very simple.
The XERO has popular support.
Maduro has a mass movement behind him.
The Child Easton movement is alive and
well,
and that's undeniable.
It doesn't matter if you hate him or
love him,
but what does the narrative like?
What are we being told?
That the narrative is that he's a
totalitarian dictator who has seized all
of power and that he has,
there's zero democracy and that everyone
wants him gone.
And that the protestors,
he keeps mowing down and executing them
whenever they come to the streets.
Not True.
100% bullshit.
I think it's [inaudible] and that's,
you see the same thing.
All these countries.
You see the same thing,
whether it be Cuba,
Venezuela,
Syria.
I have a lot of questions about the
Syria shit that we're seeing.
Um,
a lot of people that have questions
about the,
they don't believe the gas attacks.
There's a lot of people that don't think
that actually happens.
It makes no tactical sense for Assad to
do that.
When he was winning the war and was
taking back the remaining territory to
do that also didn't we let them know
that we're going to bomb them?
And like the,
I don't think anybody got killed.
We don't know.
I mean that's the thing is there's
multiple journalists who have gone to
the site of the hospital and they,
and there's very contradictory
narratives.
So we don't know until the chemical
weapons inspectors go and do their
investigation.
But why,
what I find odd is just the,
again,
uniformity with putting out these
fucking narratives by the same people
who are,
who sold to see rock.
Do you remember when Obama wanted to
bomb Syria?
And everybody's like,
fuck you.
And then it just went away.
I remember he,
yeah,
he,
he staved off.
He staved off a lot.
And unfortunately we've,
you know,
the white helmets over there,
um,
are kind of an arm of the US government
to,
we've been funding them with $200
million and on USA id,
I mean all of these groups on the
ground,
it's like whether you're Obama and you
use more covert means through USA ID and
more like drone warfare or you're the
trump John Bolton type where you're
like,
let's fucking preemptively bond on him
and kill their families and torture
their families.
I mean,
it's two sides of the same coin.
It's the empire that that's consistent
and will maintain.
But it's scary because Syria,
um,
it shows you how easy were duped,
you know,
I mean,
during the Iraq war,
it's like,
at least you had Colin Powell holding up
the vial being like,
here's the thing.
And Dan thrax now it's just like,
you just have a social media video and
we just fucking have Israel,
our garrison in the Middle East,
bomb Syria to test the waters and then
we just bombed them.
And then you have asshole like neo
liberal think tankers all paraded around
the media,
all these generals.
Right.
All these experts who are all literally
Iraq war propaganda is,
or generals or defense contractor ceos,
and they're all just like,
trump isn't doing enough.
He needs the bomb more.
This isn't sending enough of a message
to Assad.
It's like,
what have we ever,
one is bombing.
Anyone ever done anything good?
What?
Tell me when the fucking us is
intervene.
That's actually turned out good.
So don't sell this bullshit.
Humanitarianism.
It just nuts that we just keep falling
for it.
And people were like,
well,
what are we supposed to do?
Fucking don't do anything.
Don't,
don't do anything.
And I know that people are like,
oh,
you know,
isolation is ms bad.
Look the u s empires horrific and the
largest threat to humanity,
the world's biggest polluter.
I'm exempt from climate treaty's all the
shit you never see on the mainstream
media.
Why?
Because it's owned by oil,
oil corporations and defense
contractors.
That's why you see ads for Boeing and
Raytheon.
Like we're,
we're not looking to buy a tank.
When we watch the news that's just
there,
or overlords controlling the narrative,
they know the limitations of the debate.
They know that parameters and the
framing that they're allowed to work
within.
They can't even talk about the u s as an
empire of the world's biggest empire.
The world's ever seen.
Fascinating.
The difference between what you hear
from Internet commentators who are free
of networks and pr producers and
executives are telling them what to do
and sponsors and,
and the,
the version that you're getting on
television,
on CNN or on any of these,
any of these major mainstream news
networks,
you're getting a very watered down,
very homogenized and pasteurized
narrative.
Absolutely.
Because I think that's why I do the
show,
the empire files and,
and media roots radio with my brother
Robbie Martin at fluorescent gray on
twitter.
But I do the show with my partner Mike
prisoner.
Um,
because we want to retell these
narratives that have been lost.
History's always been written by the
victors.
All of the shit that we're seeing around
the world needs to be analyzed within
the lens of the u s being the largest
empire that's siphons all the fucking
money in the world for military
expenses.
I mean every issue,
domestic and internationally,
it's all shaped.
You're out there doing this,
you're traveling the Palestine,
you're traveling to Venezuela,
you doing all this stuff,
you're,
you're writing all these things,
you're doing all these videos.
Does this ever get too much for you?
Is this ever like overrun your brain?
Has this ever freak you out that none of
this is getting any better?
And in fact,
some of it's getting worse.
I mean,
it is depressing to,
like I was saying,
I mean just the,
the discourse now where I'm called a
Russian student,
I was like,
look,
I guess once a Putin puppet,
always a Putin puppet,
doesn't matter if I left our t three
years ago,
I,
you know,
I told you what they were trying this
fucking ship you off to Crimea because
yeah,
you're boots on the ground,
young lady.
Go check out the war zone.
And then the intelligence report that
came out as the definitive proof of
Russian hacking basically said,
my show that had ended two years prior
was part of the reason why trump won.
So you have all this desperation to try
to dilute the narrative and call
everyone a Russian troll and,
but yeah,
it's depressing as hell Joe,
because I feel like the sanity is
fucking lost and I can't actually have
conversations with people and talk about
reality because either you're a trump
boot licker who thinks everything's fake
news and you think q and on is gonna
fucking expose the pedophiles across the
country or you think I'm a Russian troll
because I'm saying something that goes
against the grain.
It's really disturbing.
We're living in a really,
really disturbing time.
Too much information too.
I think that's part of the problem.
I think part of the problem is a
narrative gets so diluted toxify it and
to think about,
because you know there are pedophiles
out there.
I mean whenever someone does get exposed
and some pedophile ring gets broken up,
you go,
oh,
that's real.
Why don't even think it was real?
Because these people are so fucking
stupid and some of the shit that they
believe is so dumb.
You know there are a lot of them are the
same people that are chem trail.
People are flat earth people.
There's like so much of the same shit
coming out of these people that when you
find out that there is a group of people
that are pedophiles,
that there really have been involved in
human trafficking or child slavery,
which is a real thing.
I mean this is something that's almost
like,
it's almost like been talked about by so
many wacky people that people don't
believe it until you read like the,
the story about Jimmy Savile,
how do is that?
I say his name,
the guy in England.
You're like,
wait a minute,
what?
How long did this go on for?
Or San Dusky or any of these other,
you are,
oh my God,
this is real.
This team.
Yes.
That guy.
How many gymnast were molested?
Like a hundred more.
I think it was more than a hundred
right?
This is modern times.
This is real.
Like it's almost like when you hear
about someone like that,
you're like,
that's not even possible.
How could that happen?
And then you go,
wait a minute.
He,
oh,
now he's in jail.
No,
it's true.
And all these poor gymnast are coming
out and saying,
this guy was molesting me and I will say
nine and 11 and it's fucked.
But you,
that stuff gets lost in the shuffle
because there's so much noise.
There's so much information and there's
too many things to pay attention.
You can tell him be about Venezuela.
You're telling me about Palestine.
Just those two things are bouncing back
and forth in my head.
And then what about stormy Daniels?
And then there's another guy or the Gal
he paid off all my Michael Collins
pleading the fifth shit and it's got to
happen,
right?
Jokes like as like just happened
quickly.
I mean what was also in,
in Columbia on the front lines of the
drug war that people should check out in
the empire files to and that that shit's
nuts too.
Do you know what I saw?
That was great.
But that fucking Tom Cruise movie that
my time American made made in America,
whatever it is,
American made the movie about Barry
Seal's,
who's a CIA drug runner.
Wait,
is this older?
No,
just happened a year ago.
I did not hear about that.
Very seals is the guy who was dropping
off the drugs that they would get from
the Colombian cartel and you would drop
him off in Mena,
Arkansas.
Do you know the story?
Fascinating story.
It was exposed because two kids were
there when the drugs got dropped off and
they were murdered and their bodies were
put on train tracks.
The trains ran over their bodies.
The cop said these kids were high and
they fell asleep on the train tracks.
Their parents did an independent found
out
that there's stab wounds in the kids,
so then the parents brought this
information to light.
Everything unfolds.
They find out that this is gigantic drug
ring that was supported by Bill Clinton
is a big part of the movie was that this
barry seal guys gets arrested with
millions of dollars in cash and coke and
Bill Clinton Calls Up.
The prosecutor makes them walk.
That's real.
That really did happen.
This was all in Mena Arkansas when Bill
Clinton was the governor of Arkansas.
Then goes on to be the president.
But this guy was bringing in drugs from
Columbia and from South America at the
behest of the CIA.
And it's a big part of the film now.
How much of the film is bullshit and how
much of it is real?
We don't know so much draw order of
Colombia.
I fucking walked across there is like
not,
I mean it is ridiculous how open that
shop porous.
Very porous.
The borders I'm sure.
But now Columbia is a different animal.
I mean,
I'm sure there's still growing coke
there,
but it's not what it used to be mean.
They,
you know,
both ties to be like very,
very dangerous and now it's not at all.
Yeah.
The civil war recently ended and Farc is
now d.
No.
Should I really?
It's fucking amazing.
The guy who plays Escobar is a fucking
saint.
Emily,
wait,
what's her name?
The woman in it.
She's awesome.
Anyway.
Awesome.
It's fucking great.
I mean it is really good.
Nice.
It's one of those shows where you like
at the end of it you're like,
ah.
In season two my wife shut it off.
So I can't do this anymore.
Too many people are dying.
What really happened?
Lots of Waco to it's I'm scared,
dude.
It's amazing because everyone remembers
Waco vaguely,
but wow,
you really need to watch it because it
retells the story from um,
one of the victims eyes and damn,
they killed people.
They NASA,
when you see those tanks blowing fire
into the building and they were trying
to say that it didn't happen that
fucking video of it,
you can watch the video of the tank
lighting these buildings on fire where
people are inside of them.
They were driving over the houses while
the people are inside of him.
That's when the militia movement posed a
threat to the government and now they've
just become,
isn't it weird the evolution how now
militia people are like pro trump?
It's sort of weird,
but not the guys up in Oregon that we're
trying to mooch off public land to run
their cattle.
Who knows?
They might be pro trump.
Trump just sold off the last national
parks grand staircase,
open it up for oil and gas drilling.
They probably like that Shit,
man.
Yeah,
that's an interesting thing.
Like I've heard very different versions
of that from z Zinky when that guy,
what does he,
secretary of the interior,
what does Zinky yeah,
when he was talking about it and he's
explaining to us not what happened.
And that essentially went right back to
where the way it was before Obama
changed the legislation changed the
rules.
I don't understand.
It was protected under Obama for a good
reason.
There's dinosaur fossils,
they're native Americans have monuments
there.
But of course we don't care about native
American monuments.
We just care about confederate
monuments.
We don't care about abolishing all the
native American land and all the
treaties.
We just care about protecting bizarre
confederate statues around the country.
I don't think we should protect
confederate statues and s in the sense
that I don't think they should be in
like,
you know,
the middle of fucking times,
squares and shit like that,
but they should do something with them
the same way they should do something
with Gingiss con statutes.
Do you know that most of those things
were made during the,
um,
the Jim Crow era?
That that's a really good point
constructed.
That's an amazing point.
A lot of people think that it was right
after the civil war and in fact it was
like in the 60s it was during the civil
rights movement.
There was a protest to the civil rights
move with,
oh Yay,
we'll little don't do it here.
Well here,
here's a statue.
And they're shitty statues to a lot of
them,
like really poorly constructed there.
Made him quickly.
Yeah,
it was a protest to the civil rights
movement.
A lot of them.
That's crazy.
But the thing is like they are a
representation of history.
Just like a gang is con statute would be
a representation that monster,
I mean we think of gangs.
Khan is a guy who opened up trade with
China today.
You know,
you vaguely understand that he was
responsible for the death of 10% of the
population of the world back then.
Change The fucking New York Times had an
article about how he changed the carbon
footprint of the earth.
They,
there's literally a difference in the
carbon footprint because 10% less people
were alive during gingiss Khan's reign.
They killed everybody.
They fucking quit killing millions of
people.
There's a great Dan Carlin series on it
called the wrath of the cons,
but I've talked about it way too much.
But today Gingiss comms not offensive
like you could bring up gaviscon nobody
cares me weighing more horrific than
anything that happened during the civil
war.
They had slaves and they,
they did everything they used.
They would capture people and use them
as the front line.
They'd push them towards their own
people so they would get shot.
They will be the first people to get
shot with arrows and I mean there's some
horrific shit but I think the think we
shared melt gingiss con statues.
I think the confederacy is just so much
more recent and do something with it
though.
I mean I don't think it should be in
town square for sure.
In anybody's townsquared.
Yeah,
but I think they should do something
with them instead of melting them are
smashing them.
They should put them somewhere at least
for the future.
At least for future people to like look
back.
Like,
look,
this is how fucking wacky people were in
the 1960s they construct these Omadjela
has to the 18 hundreds and slavery was
legal.
They constructed these statues to sort
of paint these people in this heroic
fashion that we're fighting to keep
black people slaves.
That's part of the thing.
There was,
this is all right,
there's a part of the history of this
country.
We've got to put it somewhere.
I mean,
I'm not saying that should be worshiped.
Definitely shouldn't be prominently
featured.
So some black kid has to filter.
Yeah,
there should be something like that.
Right?
Yeah,
and but it should be like detailed of
when it was
constructed,
it was an instructor who made it.
What was the political affiliation of
the people that created it?
Totally.
Yeah.
Totally stopped us.
Whitewash whitewashing bullshit like
that.
Every time mlk day comes around,
I'm always just like,
did you know mlk was like a rabid anti
militarist and anti imperialist?
No,
because they,
he was the most hated black man in
America.
Someone said,
know that he used to fuck all these
white women,
like who does only fucking white women.
It gives a flat of funny did.
Personally.
I can a time
that's going to be the bad day.
Oh well you just turned it around for
me.
Fuck mlk.
That I have a dream.
It's so strange that people,
they turn on things.
What do you think about this whole like
dueling narrative though about trump?
Like how he's somehow absolved from all
of his wrongdoings or he's a Russian
plant?
Like are you having trouble talking to
people about that?
Well,
what do you think?
I think the good thing about him,
this is the good thing is that we
realize now how easy it is for a person
to win the popularity contest that is
the presidency of the United States and
that you could get a popular person,
whether it's trump or whether it's oprah
or whoever the fuck it is that decides
to win next.
And this is a ridiculous way to pick the
person who runs the biggest fucking
military complex the world has ever
known.
I mean,
the greatest army the world has ever
known by far is the United States
military.
The commander in chief is now,
the guy was the host of the apprentice
that was famous for saying,
you're fired.
You're fired.
I mean,
he's,
this is,
this is a popularity contest.
It's insane.
You don't have to have special
qualifications.
You just have to be deemed the people
that,
the person that people like the most.
Yeah.
That's insane.
It's also insane to have one giant Alpha
chimp to be the top guy.
Right.
Or the top gal to run the whole project.
And I saw that with Hillary too.
There was so many people that were
looking for Hillary to win because they
wanted a woman to win because they
thought it would be historic victory
regardless of how fucking creepy she is,
regardless of all the crazy shit that
she's done,
regardless of her history,
regardless of all the fucking way that
they hacked the DNC.
And they literally conspired to keep
Bernie Sanders from winning the
nomination.
I mean,
they hacked the democracy.
They did it,
not the Russians.
And everybody's like,
like,
yeah,
yeah.
It didn't work.
Doesn't even count.
Screw voter ID,
voter suppression,
all that Shit.
Gerrymandering woman's so bad that they
were willing to look to sleep.
And then while the gay person next,
you know,
the black person and a woman,
our trans persons person,
I mean honestly,
and that's the problem.
I think that's the conflation with like
the left and the neo liberal think
tankers is that they use identity
politics to sell more corporatism.
Like they use it to brand slap pink shit
on Boeing jets and be like women's Day.
But it's not like they actually care
about oppressed and marginalized people.
So it's,
it's really interesting.
We're in an infancy.
The infancy of understanding really are,
I mean,
three people ago,
three people go and it's like three
people from now or,
but like these fucking apes were crazy.
I really do think that.
Yeah,
I think we're in the middle of it.
You know,
whether it's the apprentice guy,
I mean,
if he didn't win,
what would you want?
Fucking Ted Cruz to win?
Get the fuck out of here.
Out of his mind too.
And now all he's doing is sucking
trump's ass.
You see all those speeches about him,
dude,
crazy.
Trump calls his wife a dog that says his
dad killed jfk and just,
and Ted Cruz is like,
you know what,
I'm I really like him now.
Yeah.
Lion Chair.
I love how he calls people at name like
crazy.
Hillary lying ted.
He gives him a name.
Just a lot of things that he does that I
wish he wasn't the president.
I wish I could just laugh at some of the
things he does and I wouldn't feel bad
about it.
Right.
You know,
cause he's a fucking loon.
I mean,
he's a crazy old rich dude.
He does a bunch of wacky shit that I
find to be incredibly entertaining.
If he wasn't the leader of the free
world,
he wasn't in fucking power.
I mean,
I think if wants to be there either if
trauma,
Paul Ryan didn't want to be there
anymore,
you probably got some sweet ass deal
with some big Pharma lobby or something.
He's probably realizing like the
writing's on the wall for him.
He's like,
oh,
I see what happens if your president
fuck this.
I'm catching radiation sickness just for
being on the outside check waiting for
me.
Um,
I'm gonna go fishing,
but,
uh,
I don't,
I think the Democrats are so stupid,
Joe,
that you even saw their slogan come up
for 2018 at the literally said,
look at the other guy that was there.
That's the genius slogan.
Look at the other end to do the same
thing.
They're going to do the same thing.
Trump is gonna win again.
Guaranteed.
I guarantee you,
unless they really let Bernie Sanders,
uh,
take the reins and I just feel like
they're too threatened by his economic
policies that they're not going to buy
the time Bernie wins his head will be
right.
[inaudible] his head just keeps sinking
further,
further down.
Just keeps getting more.
Every bloody I'll go into you all the
job.
That's his latest one.
He wants to guarantee a job.
Who's going to make these jobs?
Birdie you fuck you don't know shit.
But looking at say that you can't see,
you're going to guarantee a job cause
who's gonna make the jobs?
You're just going to make up jobs.
What are you going to do?
We're going to get that money.
You get to take it from me and give it
to people because you have give him a
fake job.
Yeah.
What are you going to do?
How can you say,
I'm going to guarantee every American a
job that is a fucking insane thing to
Suzie said how?
No,
because here's the thing.
What if you just wait and you just like,
you don't want to do shit.
You're lazy.
You're a fuck up.
Well,
I guaranteed everyone a job,
but I got fired.
You guaranteed me a job here.
Then another job,
I don't want to be a liar.
Like what are you going to do?
How are you going to give everyone a
job?
It's literally not possible.
That's a fucking insane thing to say.
I guarantee a job for everybody know
it's not in the same.
Those same.
The other shit that he says,
I mean he's been out in the floor.
You have to give him credit for the last
30 years,
whether it be Gulf War syndrome,
like Gmos.
I mean he's out there fighting for,
he's
like,
it's important to have pe.
You have to have like both sides.
You have to have radical,
right radical left and let's meet all
somewhere in the middle,
you know.
But if you look at like Europe and
other,
he is considered probably center.
Yeah.
Like you look at Jeremy Corbyn,
he is like,
he's,
he's Bernie Sanders on steroids where
he,
he's,
he's in Britain.
Yeah.
And he's called a Russian,
right?
Yeah.
Dude.
But I'm,
what's crazy about the hillary
sycophants is like,
you see Neera Tanden and all these
assholes who worked for Hillary
Clinton's campaign on the fucking eve of
trump bombing Syria.
They're like,
thanks Susan.
Surandon thanks a lot.
Great job.
It's like,
Oh,
I'm sorry Susan Surandon made trump bump
series.
Dick was random.
Did it.
Thanks.
And it's also like Hillary would've
been,
would've been bombing Syria very
quickly.
She called for a no fly zone.
He's got a big Dick.
I mean,
you remember the,
everybody quickly forgets that Kadafi
Shit.
She was laughing,
laughing,
laughing.
We came,
we saw he died.
Hahaha.
Like who are you?
The what person laughs like that when
someone gets killed.
Even if bill cosby,
if some woman who bill cosby raped
showed up outside the courtroom and he
was walking down the stairs and she ran
up,
leave Harvey Oswald Jack Ruby Style and
shot him right in the chest.
I wouldn't laugh.
I'd be like,
Whoa,
that's fucking crazy.
I wouldn't be like,
she saw he's done.
Where's your pills now?
Faggot.
No,
I wouldn't say that.
I would be,
I would be freaking out.
It'd be like,
wow,
that guy just lost his like what a crazy
life that God,
that guy's life was like this magical
ride of celebrity until he got busted
raping people and then the last years of
his life were in helacious state of
being accused of something and,
and probably only got a fraction of what
he was actually,
what he actually did.
I mean,
how many women out there know that they
were raped by him and just said nothing
because they just don't,
they don't want to be a part of it.
The big.
Exactly.
And how many victims are there already?
Fuck is at least 50 at least 50 fucking
than Weinstein.
Is there anyone else that's that much of
a serial rapist?
She bit,
the Weinstein thing was like he was
forcing them to have sex with him in
order to give them roles.
Right.
He wasn't drugging them.
It's just as creepy in a way,
but it's not quite the same thing
because bill cosby was almost like a
monster or you know,
like fucking did to you while you were
passed out for a day in his house.
But he's also,
the way you posed at like Weinstein was
this fat gross got like Shrek
personified newman.
We was everybody.
Everybody knew.
Stay the fuck away from him.
Right up to his room.
He's a monster.
That was the whole thing with that guy.
But what,
what bill cosby was with this moral
voice of Black America back your pants
up.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't you have those,
those sagging jeans using all those bad
words.
Do you remember?
It was we were talking about before.
Do you remember the Eddie Murphy thing
where he called up at?
Eddie Murphy had it in his movie raw,
right.
It was in raw or delirious.
Might've been till years.
So fucking good.
But Oh man,
he got a call running a wire.
He called up Richard Pryor.
See you can find that.
So you would find that online.
Eddie Murphy on Bill Cosby because
Richard Pryor talk shit to bill cosby.
Bill cosby wasn't half the fucking
comedian that Richard Pryor was.
Yeah,
I'm sure that bothered,
I'm here.
Let's play this.
I've been not thinking this outfit down.
Bill College,
he has a good outfit and chastise me on
the phone for being too dirty on a stage
and it was real weird because I haven't
met him and he just started was you
should call me up because he was bill
and tell me that he did about what
comedy is all about.
And I sat and listened to this man
chastise me and with good cause the
chest as you used to get you grown,
you feel like one of the cosby kids
and picked up the telephone and bill got
Rohem y'all.
I was like,
Hello Mr Cosby in here.
I put like
how good Eddie Murphy was.
I'd love to tell you,
start
to tell you the story.
Children.
What did you go fly
in Massachusetts with?
Good meal and my five
children
and the boy,
the boy's name is everything you do.
Come talk from school the other day with
a big smile on his face in my son.
Looks just like me.
He walks through the door looking at me
with this.
I could not resist.
Walks up and I say,
what are you smiling?
Aw,
Joe says to me,
I'm smiling because I need money to go
see the energy back to the show.
Please give me money
if the child is smiling this way because
he needs
to get them.
I do not handle the money in the house.
My wife handles the ticket money,
so I must go
the family,
the eighties dude,
God,
I miss the,
anyway,
it is a long bit.
It's like six minutes,
50 seconds.
It's great.
Basically calls up Richard Pryor.
Yeah,
and he goes,
uh,
Richard Pryor said,
do the people,
do you get paid?
We'll tell bill to have a coke and a
smile and shut the fuck up.
But that was really,
really,
really did call him up.
Meanwhile,
while Eddie Murphy
was doing that,
you got to realize this is the 80s,
right?
So while Eddie Murphy was doing that
sketch bill cosby,
very likely it was probably raping
somebody.
Oh,
absolutely.
Plastic.
Very raping them.
Them the,
as he was on the stage.
It's entirely possible.
Yeah.
I know.
I just saw Whoopi Goldberg,
uh,
do stand up.
Have you seen her recently?
No,
it was really interesting.
I mean she's going back to the horse
just talking about her pussy.
Well yeah,
no,
it was crazy.
I thought she was going to talk about
trump or assumption.
She came out talking about her vagina's
sows so dry that she has sand coming out
of it.
And then I saw in vegas it was,
it was really,
was it good?
Um,
it was interesting to see.
It's interesting to see will be
governed,
be like extremely fucking dirty,
but it was also a thing.
Yeah.
Uncomfortably in a lot of,
um,
but then she opened it up to q and a,
which I thought was weird.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
How'd she do that?
Did you have a line of people and she
just,
she went a second,
you know,
now I'm going to open it up.
She's like,
ask,
ask me anything.
And I was like,
I don't know what the fuck.
Like what are people going to ask you?
People were like,
how,
how was a ghost?
What's it like working with those cons
on the view?
How do not murder Megan Mccain when
you're sitting next to her?
Who was the one that she used to always
get no hassle that whatever happened in
that Gal that got replaced by John
Mccain's daughter,
I guess.
How the hell is John Mccain still alive?
He's had brain cancer for like a year.
Can I get some mark surgery?
It's got some new surgery,
like gut surgery coming his brain.
It's got something going on in his gut.
It's going to have to get in test really
surgery.
Yeah.
Serious Shit.
Um,
what that Elizabeth hackle Hasselbeck
chick.
She was like the original Megan Kelly.
Yeah,
like the original hot blonde mean lady.
You know the hot blonde mean
conservative lady.
Just shut your ass down.
So fucking market for those hot blonde
mean conservative ladies at tough
market.
Good market.
Yup.
You know,
again,
filling that vacuum,
the Tommy Lauren's,
they love it.
Get pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
How weird is it that Megan Kelly's just
now this like weird talk show host?
Just a normal like an ellen.
She's like trying to rebrand ourself as
an allen.
It's like you cannot go from like Fox
News mouthpiece,
you know,
frothing at the mouth about all the shit
to just being like,
hey,
let's just talk about your relationship
problems.
There's just an odd switch.
Yeah.
But I don't buy it.
Fangs come out every now and then.
Yeah.
The Jane Fonda Shit.
You know what the Jane Fonda Shit,
she asked Jane Fonda about plastic
surgery and Jane Fonda,
fuck you asking me about plastic
surgery.
I'm here to promote a movie,
right?
Oh,
we have three minutes.
You know what would I look good?
Yeah,
but except that she's talked about
having plastic surgery.
So why,
why?
That's a weird,
because she's,
this is not organic,
right?
These shows are not,
or it's not a podcast.
I'm just sitting down talking.
Yeah.
So she wants to get some sound bite and
this is probably like part the agenda.
So Jane Fonda's shut her down and just
start talking about the movie again and
then talked about her and so then later
on it looks damn good.
She's not not bad for 150,000 years old.
So later,
later on Megan Kelly started talking
shit about Jane Fonda on the air saying
about how people used to call her
annoyed Jane.
Let's see the fans come out and utr
number when she said she had alluded to
the fact that trump poisoned her the
morning of the debate.
I think we talked about that.
What?
Yeah,
well she got coffee from some weird
driver the morning of the debate and we
already know that that crazy shit was
happening between her and trump.
And she said she got violently ill.
She was trying to tell him I don't drink
coffee.
And then he was like,
no drink.
It's good.
She drank the coffee got violently ill
and had to like sit next to a puke
bucket almost thinking that she would
have to cancel the debate.
Basically alluding to the fact that
trump might have poisoned her that day.
I swear on,
I don't know.
I have never taken a coffee from some
strange way to force me to drink.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
and I'm not as famous.
She's recanted it after he got elected,
maybe out of fear,
maybe she was like,
oh shit,
if he really did do this,
then a bull shit,
their pants.
Once he got elected,
scorched earth.
I mean he made a lot of enemies and a
lot of people made enemies with him.
It's going to be really interesting to
see what happens with all these criminal
charges and what's going to happen with
Colin and all these other people.
The Mueller investigation.
It's so strange because it's all just,
we're waiting for something to be highly
illegal and obvious and it's not yet.
So I'm like,
where's the thing?
And when the thing comes out and people
start going down,
they start going to jail.
Well,
who's going to rat him out?
What's going to happen?
I can get a part in them.
I mean,
that's going to impeach him.
You have to have a consensus in the
Republican majority Congress.
So I don't understand how that's going
to happen unless he perjures himself.
Right.
The perjury trap like Bill Clinton,
unless he says some shit on the stand.
But I think it that he's smart enough to
just say yes.
No,
I don't know.
Hopefully saying I want them to be
fucking nph.
I fucking hate that guy.
The trumps.
And people were saying that trump's
supporters,
hence to public and trump's supporters
are the ones that okayed the Mueller
raid on Cohen's office.
Right.
What do you mean do I miss that?
The,
the people that rated Mueller's office,
right.
That trump supporters,
republicans had to give the green light.
Oh yeah.
The judge was appointed by trump.
Ah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So this is like this.
There must have been overwhelming
evidence.
The crazy thing about this is it's
almost like game of thrones,
like it's playing out so slow and I was
like a year and a half.
And you're like,
where is the proof?
It's trays.
It,
it just keeps building and people keep
getting indicted and people keep getting
pulled in.
And Cohen just pleaded the fifth.
Right.
And is that what happened?
That little pussy cushner gets indicted
for something man that have you heard
the one speech he gave and you've never
heard from him again?
Because his voice sounds like a little
mouse,
like rescue talk.
There's a good reason for that.
Can Be bad like this.
He's like,
he reminds me of American psycho.
Yeah,
totally.
Dude.
Just as there's a lot of audible,
like look,
looking at screens.
J.
Crew.
Oh God,
he's such a disgusting.
I'm there.
Let me hear it.
Let me get President Donald J.
Trump.
When my father in law decided to run for
president,
I served this campaign the best I could
because I believe in him and his ability
to improve the lives.
How does Donald let that guy fuck his
dog?
And he wants the Fucker,
right?
So it's like,
how are you letting this weird Guy
Fucker?
He only let some fucking,
only if I'm in the room,
they do it right.
Praiser
touch your feet.
I did not collude with Russia.
I like.
He's like,
I did not collude with Russia more than
I want to hear his voice.
Fast.
Americans and now serving the president
and the people of the United States has
been the honor and privilege of a
lifetime.
Oh my God,
I am so grateful.
I believe the opportunity.
I'm sold unimportant,
man.
Middle East peace.
Hold up and duck has a man of character.
She has a strong will.
I bet that motherfucker's never quits.
Middle East,
the Middle East,
conflict number.
When he was like,
you know what,
jared Kushner is actually going to solve
the peace between Israelis and
Palestinians.
Interesting.
I would like to see that guy hike with a
heavy backpack.
See how long before he starts crying?
I bet he's got about 14 minutes in them.
I want to see him.
Can you imagine him doing anything
strenuous at all?
His hands are probably like silk.
They probably do this thing well,
the a little tiny hands.
He puts his hands in paraffin wax every
now and just let them sit.
Do you know he gets manicures for sure.
Oh Good God.
Strange,
strange character.
Probably gets a little facial every day.
His wife,
his wife is hot.
Donald's daughter is flushing.
She got a lot of work.
Tons.
Are we going to sound really whatever
I'm doing,
I'm not against getting work done style.
I don't know about that.
That's like weird shit.
That's like changing your ethnicity.
That's nuts.
But yeah,
jared Kushner is nuts.
Um,
all these people are men.
They have a kid,
right?
Oh,
they have a bunch.
I think they just had their third child
hammering it somehow there.
Look,
she's smoking hot.
Well you go,
what do you do if I were trump,
I don't want to fuck her too.
Woo.
No,
it's,
it's interesting too,
like stormy Daniels and the other woman
who said,
you know that she had an affair with
trump.
She said that both of them said that
trump told her,
you remind me of my daughter,
Ivanka,
you're beautiful and smart.
And then they had sex.
Hollow Holla,
play.
Can't bang new kid.
But you can bang someone who looks like,
Ooh.
Yeah.
I remember when Ted Cruz liked porn
treat.
Did he,
did he show he did that or saying in his
staff biggest fucking hand because the
woman in the porn video looked exactly
like his wife.
Oh Jesus.
Louisa's who,
what,
what presidential candidate is ever
going to come out and say,
I just,
I love
porn.
It's great.
You know,
I can masturbate and then they'd be done
with it and I don't have to have sex
with anybody.
Yeah,
that's great.
Why not?
I mean,
well,
Obama admitted that he almost shot up
heroin.
It's like,
why couldn't trump have just said,
yeah,
I banged a porn star.
Who did he say he almost shot up heroin.
Said the needle was like,
oh yeah,
he said that he was almost going to do
it and he was sitting there and yeah,
that's heavy,
but like,
why did trump go through this whole nda
nonsense knowing that it could even him
vitamin the ass.
Yeah.
He probably thought that Michael Cohen
had it locked down and then,
you know,
they pay people off in the past.
I guess,
and it probably no one cared until he
became president.
Right.
What's your president?
And they're like,
oh,
the scrutiny is just so overwhelming.
I mean,
it's not just a scrutiny from the
American media,
it's the scrutiny all across the world.
Right.
I mean,
everybody's paying attention to
everything you've ever done,
ever.
And with him,
with him,
honestly,
the thing that scares me is not that,
the thing that scares me is all the
business deals.
What's crazy is how many small business
owners went under because trump had
these relationships,
apparently,
allegedly,
whatever I have to say with,
you know,
he would,
they would do these construction jobs
and small contractors,
which is not get paid.
And they would have to sue and they
would wind up going under.
They couldn't,
they couldn't compete with them.
And this is something that Joey Dee has
talked about on the podcast,
and he knew people that were involved
and construction companies that went
under because trump fuck them.
Oh Wow.
This is like a standard thing that he
would do back then.
Not pay people.
Damn.
Yeah.
I mean,
he had a reputation,
it's called Google.
Trump had a reputation for not paying
contractors,
construction contractors.
It was,
it was a real issue.
And it's an issue of character and
morals and ethics that is,
to me,
way more important than who he decides
to have sex.
Hundreds alleged.
Donald Trump doesn't pay his bills.
Oh God,
look at it.
It's all just what box?
Dishwasher.
Say billionaire didn't pay dishwashers.
Painters.
Waiters.
Yeah,
the lowly minions.
You know,
and then you know how much of that is,
he doesn't really pay because someone
else pays form and it got lost in the
shuffle.
And you know,
there's a giant slumlord too.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean it looks like a slumlord.
Criminals.
I mean,
you got to hear that guy being trump,
having as much money in property as you
do and not having any criminal activity.
I mean,
how the hell you can't be that fucking
be hard.
You'd have to know a few crooks,
you know,
and just the amount of money that's
involved,
like how the fuck can you pay attention
to all that?
Like you'd have to have someone like to
think that he's responsible for all that
is also naive honestly because if you
really look at the amount of properties
at trump owns and to think that he's
paying attention to all that and the
management of all that and the paying of
the contractors and all that,
but it probably trickles down from the
top right.
The kind of ethics that would be
involved and not paying off contractors.
That's like the whole Russia thing just
kills me because like we were saying,
it's been a year and a half.
There has been no smoking gun.
It's just a whole bunch of little things
like Oh,
Russian trolls online.
Right.
This,
that the DNI report,
which I was in,
um,
but no one is talking about the fact
that he obviously has ties with Saudi
Arabia,
Turkey,
Israel,
like all,
there's collusion with all these
countries.
Why just stop it?
Russia,
would you see what he said today?
He said that Komi lied and that he did
stay the night in Russia.
Komi lied in his memo.
That's me saying,
no,
I did not catch that.
This is the latest,
oh Ooh,
something happened.
He's realized that they,
they,
they found his flight records and they
realize that the jet was in Russia for
more than 24 hours.
So then he said call me lied.
I never said I didn't s stay the night
in Russia.
So it's like,
Ooh,
this is,
this is a strange move here.
Cause this is either check or checkmate.
Like this is a sneaky one.
Like what happens here?
Cause you're Colombian line.
If Komi lied,
the whole thing's fucked.
If comi really did lie,
mistake,
the whole thing's fucked.
And if trump lied and Komi somehow or
another have some recording or something
of it,
I don't know if that's the case.
It's awesome
juice.
I just don't think that,
yeah,
the Russia collusion thing,
it's like where is the smoking gun?
Or where is it?
I mean,
all we see are these,
this Hamilton 68 dashboard that's
literally run by the Chertoff Group.
Michael turned off was bushes,
dhs Hamilton 68 dash.
What's the think tank that you see
unquestioning needed repeated in every
single article about Russian trolls
where it's like Russian trolls are
spreading nra shit online to try to
foment discontent in this country are
Russian trolls are promoting Bernie
sanders or a Russian trolls are
promoting Jill Stein.
When you look at the actual methodology
of how they determine who's a Russian
Bot and who's a Russian troll,
it all comes from this think tank run by
literally Iraq war propagandists Bill
Crystal and Michael Chertoff.
So that's what I'm saying.
These narratives are so,
it's so obscure to find out who's really
managing the narratives,
but it really is all the same people
selling where they're corniness.
Again,
they're canniness
because we want the end goal of the
empire is basically Russia,
China,
Iran,
Iran and Syria.
The steppingstones basically ultimately
to China and Russia and um,
those are the biggest competitors with,
with the empire.
And so they want to just foment that hot
war with Russia.
You know what,
I've been going down a rabbit hole with
Chinese electronics.
Weiwei got banned from 18 and t and
verizon and all these other walway is
the number three phone manufacturer in
the world.
And they also manufacture network
equipment.
And there's some,
so it seems to me like,
and this is my conspiratorial mind and
I'm just going to say right away,
I'm a moron and I know very little about
this,
but this is what,
this is what's fascinating.
The Huawei makes some really good cell
phones,
like beautiful 40 megapixel camera,
excellent design,
gorgeous screen.
And they were about to be launched
America under a t and t and then the
State Department warned against people
buying walway phones,
sitting their spy devices and told
people to not buy walway phones.
So weird.
Then they're bringing up charges against
wowway for something to do with Iran.
So,
and then there was an article today,
this is where it gets really weird,
the compliance of the media.
There was an article today about this,
the drop in sales of Chinese cell
phones.
It's Chinese cell phone sales plummet by
21% I was reading today.
Um,
but what,
like what is happening here?
Like they were saying that there was
some networking equipment that was made
by waterway that was sending,
was sending a certain amount of data
that didn't seem right and they believe
that some something was encoded in their
software and their hardware that allowed
them to hack into it and extract data
and use this as a spying device.
So then they were saying that this is
the case with the phones and these,
we shouldn't buy these wowway phones.
But then the android people,
I sent Jamie a couple articles on it
because I was fascinated by this.
I really like 30 articles about it.
I'm like in like the last week and a
half,
and these real smart tech people were
like,
this is horseshit.
First of all,
if these devices did have something in
them other than stock android or android
with a whatever they're a operating
system is that they put on over it like
their skin,
you would see it.
These guys would be able to see it.
They'd be able to find it.
This isn't,
they're not any more sophisticated.
These people,
well,
there's just something going on.
There's something going on.
There's some weirdness to it all.
It's like they might be trying to tank
these companies.
They might be like,
there might be a concerted effort,
and then the thought was that maybe
perhaps there's some sort of a deal with
Samsung and iphones,
which are the two top manufacturers to
keep out this third party,
which makes these really high end cell
phones like this.
The wowway has this porsche design mate
pro,
our s it's $2,000 it's like the most
expensive cell phone you could buy.
This thing is off the charts.
Awesome.
I mean it takes like nighttime a photo.
It turns it into like almost daylight,
like crazy 40 megapixel,
like
adjustable aperture,
like like as good as it gets in terms of
like modern day cell phones.
They're saying,
don't buy it,
don't buy it.
It's a spy device.
The tech guys are going,
you're out of your fucking mind.
You're like,
if she shouldn't buy it because they
don't update them very well.
By devices,
I mean,
yeah,
I'm sure.
I mean,
okay.
I,
I talk about something and I don't type
it in.
I don't write a message.
I don't write an email and I'll see an
ad,
so it's fine on us all the time.
That doesn't happen to you.
I,
it hasn't happened to me,
but it's happened to enough people that
I believe you.
It's insane.
Well,
I believe you know what?
No matter what,
but really crazy.
I've talked to so many people that have
had that happen.
Somebody sent me a tweet yesterday that
said they were listening to a podcast
that were doing,
we were talking
about something and then that's
something appeared in their Google ads
and he's like,
I never looked up this.
I never,
and oh no.
It wasn't a google ad.
It was a youtube search.
It was a youtube suggested.
He's like my fucking computers
listening.
Yup.
Pewter.
And what APP is doing this?
I mean,
I'm about to just go to a flip phone
because I don't want to,
it's,
it's bullshit.
We know that youtube audio is being
listened to because they're mining it to
for ad ad stuff already.
It's not even,
it's not a spy thing that's just out
there.
That's how they do it.
Right.
But is that if you're playing things?
Yeah,
so when we're playing,
so if he's playing a podcast on Youtube,
youtube listening to that and that's how
they suggest it's just happening in
their ads.
What I think might be happening with
people are noticing now is not just that
it's happening within the software.
It's that your actual device,
the microphone is on and the Laptop
camera is on.
So people block the camera with tape.
They're not blocking the microphone.
Yeah,
exactly.
How the hell do you block the
microphone?
Don't even know where it is.
How do I,
how can we have like some sort of
tutorial about like how are we can
prevent all of our shit from being
collected?
Like that whole,
the facebook,
Cambridge analytica thing.
I feel like everyone missed the boat of
what that story was.
You heard about that,
right?
The Cambridge Analytica,
they're data mining all your shit.
It's like,
yeah,
if you're on facebook,
everything's being taken in data mind.
That's very obvious.
But what wasn't really investigated,
I think channel four did this crazy
investigation where they pretended like
they were a patron trying to hire
Cambridge Analytica,
some billionaire dude,
and they put them on camera.
It's all recorded.
The guys are basically like,
it's basically like a private
intelligence from almost like a black
water where you going to hire
mercenaries to set up honeypots with
prostitutes,
take down politicians,
spy on them.
They set up shell companies with mis six
massaad.
Um,
it's all just untraceable shit.
They just go sit out.
They said they can ghost in out of
countries.
They literally said that they staged the
entire Kenyan election.
They were like,
we staged the whole thing.
We wrote all the speeches.
Yeah.
Can this gentleman,
this is,
this is backed by a billionaire,
Robert Mercer,
the same guy who come behind us.
Channel Four did a crazy investigation
about it and the,
and so that's why I'm just like,
why is everyone focusing on facebook
data?
This is like a crazy,
that's stupid game that people play was
it is called for farmland Farmville or
something world farm.
Fuck yeah.
What is that shit?
Farmville.
Yeah.
That,
that's what people were talking about.
Oh,
you're going to have data about the cows
I buy here.
Like changing the government or they're
killing people and like the band and
Knights and the Breitbart people are,
how many other colors
please are there like this?
I always think,
yeah.
Well we're all focused on Russian
trolls.
14 Russian trolls in St Petersburg.
How many companies like Cambridge
Analytica,
like blackwater?
Like all these things are operating
around the world doing all this gotta be
a fuck load a lot.
Yeah.
There's gotta be a lot that we don't
know of because it's only when,
when something fucks up or someone gets
shot in the head and like,
yeah.
Was He wearing?
Yeah.
And they're like,
Whoa,
what is that?
Oh,
change the Kenyan elections.
Cool.
Like in cell,
we never heard of a sudden people are
talking about it.
There's got to be so many of those
things that are just bubbling up in the
distance.
Disturbing.
Well,
you said,
how do I deal?
You got to do art and you got to go on
hikes and go explore nature.
Yeah.
But you are,
do you ever want to like knock,
concentrate?
Do you ever feel like it's not gonna do
any good like,
this is,
this is my,
my question that I give to everybody
who's like an activist who's very
adamant about change and doing
something.
Do you ever feel like you just don't
want to participate anymore and just
want to just,
just,
someone asked me the other day,
they said,
you know,
you have to admit that you wouldn't
rather live anywhere in the world other
than here.
And I said,
I,
I would because I can't have a kid here
because I don't have maternity leave and
I don't have any help.
I was like,
so,
no,
I,
I stay here because I have to and I have
to fight.
It's not about me and it's not about
myself.
It's about the greater good.
And it's about putting this information
out there because,
especially in the trump era,
I feel like no one is really criticizing
him in the correct way and putting it in
the proper context of the u s empire.
And I feel like I need to do that.
And,
um,
I,
I don't get sick of it and I don't think
that,
you know,
even if you do get burnt out and you get
tired,
you just have to keep going because this
is,
you don't have to,
you don't do it for recognition.
You don't do it to be on a magazine
cover because you're never going to be
rewarded in the system that we live in,
that we're going to always live on the
margins and we're going to always fight
on the margins.
Um,
and that's just the way it is.
Do you hope to somebody who's listening
so that alters their perception and then
somehow or another it spreads.
Yeah,
I think history is instructive and I
think that's why,
that's why I do what I do.
I want to instruct people about how
history has shaped our reality today and
how we can use it to learn and prevent
similar atrocities from continuing.
I mean,
I just hope that we can evolve to the
point where we can do that.
You essentially work for yourself now,
right?
I worked for Telesur tell a store is a,
um,
also state media six Latin American
countries and including Venezuela and
including Cuba,
Ecuador,
um,
and,
and some other countries fun tell a
sore,
but because of the sanctions that trump
has put on a Venezuela,
it's,
it's on a tedious leg.
So um,
it sucks that the only other place that
you can go is really just begging you
for donations on Patrion.
But as the empire files that is it
through Telstra?
We,
yeah,
so we are pro,
I have a production company and I
produced the show and then I sell it to
them.
But you say begging for donations.
I really don't see it that way because
if you just give people the option,
I bet people would be more than willing
to support your,
your work if they're interested in your
work.
And it seems like there's so many people
out there that would be now and it'd be
a great way to be completely independent
and not beholden to any state run group
or anything else.
You just basically be putting out
content and people didn't like it
anymore.
They wouldn't pay for it anymore.
Yeah,
no,
I think that,
well,
I'm not beholding to anyone because I
don't really have anyone telling me what
to do.
Like in Venezuela,
I was interviewing the defense minister,
no one vetted my questions.
I was confronting him about all this
crazy shit.
I mean,
no one in corporate media would be
allowed to do that with our government.
But yeah,
to your point,
I think that we've just gotten to a
place with journalism and media where,
um,
that's the way it is.
Like you have to invest in the
journalists that you want to support and
that's just the way that the world
works.
Because media is not a sustainable
business if you want it to be holding
power to account.
But it seems like that's not the worst
thing in the world to have something
like Patrion or some similar type of a
situation where people can just donate.
And I have that on media roots.
Um,
and on my podcast,
media roots radio,
I do have a Patriot in there.
But yeah,
you're right.
I mean to do it.
But to do investigative journalism,
it's hard one to do documentaries.
It takes a lot of money and time.
And um,
I think that's probably where it'll end
up if we keep going down the road that
we are,
which is,
you know,
whether it be our to your teleseminar,
this,
this a fear campaign against state media
and against the Russian propaganda.
Yeah.
And um,
yeah,
it's tough.
So we'll just keep trying to f uh,
speak that truth.
Yeah.
Well I'm glad you're out there swinging.
You know,
it's,
it's a scary job and punching up.
You go to crazy places too.
I mean you're not,
you're not swinging from the comfort of
your own home.
You're,
you're out there in the war zone.
It was scary when I confronted soldiers
in Columbia because I realized that I
could probably die either by hazing or a
mine.
Like,
cause there's mines all over the fucking
place and they were just like,
you need to leave right now if you want
to live
basically.
And I was like,
okay,
well see you later.
See you later guys.
That's why I asked if ever does seems
like,
how long do you,
do you see yourself doing this until
you're an old lady?
You know,
I think that if I have a family things I
might put,
you know,
I will knock you out.
It's the governor's going to hook your
boyfriend.
How do you pot?
They're going to give them a cup of
coffee from strange man.
Shut the fuck up and drink.
And if you want a family getting a
whole,
um,
no,
I think that if I have a family,
yeah,
things might change where I might not
put my life on the line.
So often we are,
I would imagine so.
But um,
yeah,
I mean I have to,
someone's got to keep poking holes in
this bullshit because it just keeps
happening and we keep getting duped and
someone has to be out there countering
the narrative and telling these stories
from marginalized and oppressed people
who have not been given those platforms.
And I have to keep doing that part.
Well,
I would suggest you stay offline for a
couple of weeks after this one just to
avoid the shit storm.
And a,
it's always great seeing you.
Thanks so much everyone.
Check out Abby martin.org and the empire
files and media roots.
Thank you so much,
Joe.
You are amazing.
Everyone check out.
Joe's stand up and a Abby Martin on
twitter and instagram is just the gram
fat babs.
I liked that.
You remember?
I remember that.
I've got fabulous.
Fabulous.
Thank you so much.
[inaudible]
hm?